[musique]
Ran Branco, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Bonne année. Est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ?
Bonne année à vous. Donc je suis Branca,
j'ai un parcours un peu spécial parce
que je suis un né dans la classe euh
contre laquelle je suis entré en guerre
il y a quelques années à travers des
livres et des enquêtes sur le
fonctionnement de nos dirigeants. J'ai
eu un parcours un peu à travers des
institutions où où on prend les
décisions au nom du peuple et souvent
contre les intérêts du peuple de façon
volontaire ou non. J'écris un livre qui
est s'appelle Crépuscule qui décrivait
la façon dont ce système oligarchique
tel que je décrivais fonctionner pour
prendre la main sur sur la volonté
populaire. Et de façon générale, j'ai
toujours eu la curiosité du monde. Donc
j'ai beaucoup voyagé sur des zones de
guerre au Kivou, au Centrafrique. Plus
récemment, je me suis beaucoup intéressé
au narcotrafic et on va peut-être
pouvoir en parler. J'étais à Kouacan, en
Haïti.
Je travaillais sur des dossiers assez
sensibles en France, notamment le
piratage récent du ministère de
l'intérieur dont je pense qu'il faudrait
qu'on parle parce que il est très
significatif à à bien des égards. Et on
a décidé de lancer un mouvement qui
s'appelle les ruches, on est 25000 dans
dans l'intention de commettre un coup
d'état légal en France, c'est-à-dire de
prendre le pouvoir et de le rendre au
peuple à travers des des instruments de
de décision collective. le référendum
initiative citoyenne, les mandats
impératifs et révocatoires, l'élection
des juges, des choses un peu qui qui
nous apparaissent de nature à à changer
la nature de oui de changer la nature de
notre démocratie qui est aujourd'hui
moribonde et qui surtout est en train de
nous mener à la guerre. Donc j'ai je
suis dans une situation oùù l'inquiétude
est importante parce que la guerre
s'approche parce que nos dirigeants ont
intérêt à nous y précipiter et on essaie
de créer des forces collectives pour y
résister et pour s'assurer que nos
enfants et nous-mêmes ne voyons pas nos
vies détruites par leurs ambitions et
leur médiocrité.
Que le prochain sacrifice soit le nôtre.
Alors, on va parler aujourd'hui
politique internationale, Union
européenne, on va parler Russie,
Ukraine, Venezuela, narcotrafic, pas
narcotrafic, politique intérieure
française, paysanerie, on a plein de
sujets. On commence par les pingouins,
Grenland, Trump, l'Union européenne.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe avec le
Groenlande ? Bah, il se passe qu'on
n'est pas capable d'envoyer un SNLE pour
euh signaler aux États-Unis qu'il faut
euh fixer des limites euh quant à leur
euh ambition destructrice. On est dans
une situation où pour reprendre les mots
d'un sous-marins, nuclaire euh lanceur
d'engin, donc euh
euh une grande partie de notre
composante marine et aussi nucléaire qui
nous permet de envoyer des signaux à nos
adversaires et de leur indiquer qu'il y
a des limites que l'on accepte pas. On
est dans ce paradoxe où nos dirigeants
d'un côté
veulent absolument rester au sein de
l'Union européenne et de l'autre sont
incapables de la défendre comme entité
géopolitique à part entière. Le les
États-Unis et l'administration Trump en
particulier veulent se saisir d'une
partie d'un territoire qui est rattaché
à l'Union européenne, le Groenland.
Et on a le président de la République
qui dans son insuffisance notoire et
chronique se content d'un entretien au
pied élevé qu'on que certains ont vu
mais c'est qu'on on manque même de de
l'écouter aujourd'hui où il dit qu'il ne
croit pas que ce soit possible que
Donald Trump fasse une chose pareille et
on s'en tient là. Or, c'est un enjeu
stratégique parce que c'est évidemment
la question du passage
de l'Arctique et donc du contact entre
les différentes zones civilisationnelles
et notamment entre la Russie et les
États-Unis, mais aussi la Chine par
Ricochet qui a a un besoin d'accès à ses
mères avec l'évolution des ressources.
Est-ce que ça va impliquer en terme
d'accès à une partie des euh des
éléments qui sont détenus par le
Groenland, notamment l'uranium ? Et donc
on est dans une circonstance où euh où
où on est pris en fait à rebour. Je
pense que il a raison Donald Trump, je
pense d'ironiser sur le Danemark qui dit
qu'ils avaient après, je sais pas si
c'est lui qui l'a dit, mais en tout cas
après les premières déclarations qu'il
avait faites, le Danemark avait annoncé
qu'ils allaient envoyer et c'est vrai
euh un deuxième
une deuxième esquade à Trénau pour
défendre le Groenland. Mais on est
réellement sur une situation, il y a
quelques dizaines de soldats seulement
qui sont disposés sur une des zones les
plus stratégiques
aujourd'hui et les plus disputés parce
qu'évidemment avec la fonte des glaces,
on a on a on a justement sur la question
des passages dont je parlais un
véritable enjeu et donc on a on a un
continent qui est complètement
je vulgaire à la ramasse mais en tout
cas qui est en retard sur sur la volonté
de puissance qui est exprimée par les
États-Unis et par les autres forces
forces
force géopolitique et surtout on sait
pas où on se place. On sait pas où on se
place et on l'a vu aussi avec le
Venezuela tout récemment. D'une part, la
France qui est complètement au fraise,
c'est-à-dire un président de la
République qui pense que le désir des
États-Unis est de provoquer un
changement de régime et qui donc tente
d'anticiper
sur celui-ci en proposant déjà un nombre
de remplaçant à monsieur Madourau qui
venait d'être de se faire enlever. Et en
réalité euh Trump n'avait pas du tout
l'intention de produire un changement de
régime, simplement de d'imposer un
rapport de force plus favorable aux
intérêts des États-Unis. Et Emmanuel
Macron se retrouve ridicule d'une part
parce qu'il n'a pas condamné la manœuvre
et l'illégalité, la violation du droit
international et d'autre part évidemment
les l'humiliation derrière de la
diplomatie française qui se fait
renvoyer dans les cordes par des
autorités vénézuéennes qui sont restées
en place malgré l'enlèvement de Nicolas
Maduro et qui émettent un une note
verbale particulièrement singlante qui
nous laisse un peu à la marge de la
diplomatie internationale parce qu'
incapable d'exiger le respect des
principes pour lesquels on est censé se
battre au sein du conseil. de de
sécurité de l'ONU. Alors, quelque chose
qui n'a pas du tout été noté, mais c'est
normal parce qu'il y a plus de
journaliste en France, c'est que le
quedors semble se rebiffer à l'égard de
l'Élysée.
Vous avez passé au qu d'ors ? J'ai été
au quedet pendant un an et ce que j'ai
vu c'est que le représentant permanent
de la France au conseil de sécurité à
l'ONU à New York lors de la séance
extraordinaire qui était convoquée sur
la situation du Venezuela qui était à la
demande de la Colombie sauf erreur de ma
part a tenu un discours beaucoup plus
dur que celui du président de la
République en condamnant évidemment la
violation de droits international de
façon très ferme.
Manuel Macron a forcément validé le
discours. Non, moi je pense qu'il y a eu
un une reprise en main du pouvoir par le
Qué d'Orset qui commence à comprendre
que c'est un président illégitime, ce
qui est le cas, qui a réussi lui un coup
d'état institutionnel de façon
intéressante à partir de de juin juillet
2024. C'est-à-dire qu'il a réussi à
imposer que reste au sommet du pouvoir
ces hommes qui a gardé son pouvoir de
domination sans le partager avec les
forces politiques qui étaient les plus
représentatives selon le peuple français
au cours de ces élections et qui est en
train d'essayer de se bunkeriser sur
cette fin de mandat probablement par
peur de finir comme Nicolas Sarkozy.
essa de maintenir et d'alimenter ces
réseaux d'allégance dans la magistrature
euh euh au sein des préfets et ainsi de
suite. Et donc, on se retrouve une
situation où peu à peu les
administrations retrouvent un peu un peu
vraiment à la marge mais quand même un
réflexe de fierté quand les intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation comme c'était
le cas sur une situation comme celle-ci
sont en jeu. Moi je pense que la
stratégie d'Emmanuel Macron, c'était de
se placer dans le sillage de Donald
Trump pour immédiatement essayer de
placer les grandes forces économique
française notamment total dans la phase
d'après de ce qu'il pensait être la
phase d'après l'exploitation des
ressources au Venezuela. et en en
anticipant sur le réel et en et en se
subordinant d'une telle façon à l'égard
de Trump, il a fini par se ridiculiser
de telle sorte que quelques jours plus
tard, je pense que là pour le coup tout
le monde l'a vu, Donald Trump s'est
littéralement fichu de sa de sa tête
dans une vidéo en limitant et et en le
tournant en dérision
pour signaler le manque de respect que
qu'il avait à son égard mais aussi par
ricochet. À notre égard, rappelez-vous
que cet été, on avait fait convoquer
l'ambassadeur des États-Unis du fait de
propos inacceptable qui constitu
ingérence dans la situation politique
française et celui-ci n'a pas daigné se
rendre à cette convocation.
Occupé
et ça n'arrive jamais. Il n'y a à aucun
moment dans aucun pays, même les plus
fragiles, quand une autorité politique
convoque souveraine un ambassadeur
étranger, celui-ci répond ou se voit
sortir du pays manu militarie. Là, on
est dans une situation avec révocation
d'élètes de créance et et ainsi de
suite. On est dans une situation où on a
on a un inservissement qui est
structurel. On on a beaucoup parlé, je
pense dans de vos chaînes avec euh
beaucoup a été dit sur sur dans vos
émissions sur sur Alstom, sur Technipp
et et d'autres entreprises qui ont été
littéralement pillées par les
États-Unis. On n' pas parlé de choses
plus qui ont été plus directement au
cœur de l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron
comme l'affaire Uber, la façon dont
Emmanuel Macron a fait rentrer Uber sur
le territoire français et lui a donné
une position quasi monopolistique parce
que vous savez comment ça se passe en
réalité. On est sur un marché qui est
naissant qui est celui des VTC qui vient
concurrencer le marché traditionnel des
taxis. Et donc la seule façon de prendre
des parts de marché c'est de baisser les
prix. Donc c'est d'être très attirant
pour le chalant et de fonctionner à
perte.
pendant un temps euh tout en payant
correctement les les chauffeurs. Donc la
première phase du ber en France, les
chauffeurs étaient bien payé, ça coûtait
quasiment rien pour pour les les
consommateurs. Et en réalité, tout ça
était financé par du capital à risque,
c'estàdire par des dizaines de milliards
de dollars qui avaient été injectés dans
Uber de façon à ce qu'il puisse pendant
des mois et des mois perdre des dizaines
des centaines de millions d'euros mais
que ça lui permett d'écraser tous les
concurrents, y compris les concurrents
français. Et donc Emmanuel Macron comme
secrétaire général adjoint d'Élysée puis
comme ministre de l'économie a laissé
faire ça. Il y a eu des réunions, ça a
été révélé par les Uber Files où il a
allégé le cadre réglementaire y compris
permis et laissé passer des violations
graves du droit français par cette
entreprise en essence d'un appui en
pardon en échange d'un appui factuel à
sa campagne avec toute une série de de
services qui ont été rendus.
Sur la politique internationale.
Mais ça c'est de la politique
internationale parce que c'est de
l'argent. Aujourd'hui, on a un acteur
monopolistique sur ce secteur en France
et un/ers
de chaque course Uber part en
Californie. Et donc c'est des millions
d'euros qui chaque année sont nous ser
alors que la valeur rajoutée est nulle.
Vous mettez 12 polytechniciens, vous les
enfermez et trois Normals, vous les
enfermez dans une chambre pendant
pendant 3 mois. Il vous fabrique un Uber
français nourriture,
pardon
avec ou sans nourriture ? euh avec
nourriture parce qu'il faut qu'ils
soient efficace et euh et vous les vous
les enfermez dans un dans des dans un
pay de la République même vous les
mettez vous les mettez mais en 3 mois
ils vous pondre l'algorithme,
l'application euh mais sans aucune
difficulté et vous imposez une solution
souveraine parce qu'en en réalité comme
c'est des marchés c'est pas des marchés
c'est c'est des ce qu'on appelle des
monopoles naturels. C'est comme les
trains, c'est comme l'énergie. Il y a
c'est quand on a essayé de faire la
concurrence sur EDF euh avec la
distribution d'électricité, on s'est
retrouvé à inventer des faux acteurs qui
ont arraché des centaines de millions
d'euros à la France sans aucune valeur
ajoutée supplémentaire. Juste en jouant
sur les paramètres commerciaux. Je te
fais une offre qui mais à la fin en
réalité il n'y avait aucune plusvalue.
Au contraire on perdait de l'argent
parce qu'on est obligé de rémunérer tous
ces intermédiaires. Et donc c'est des
c'est des marchés qui sur lesquels la
privatisation n'a aucun sens. Donc on
fait une offre publique, l'équivalent
d'un Uber public et on règle ce problème
et l'argent reste en France. Et si vous
faites ça sur les différents points de
l'économie qui ont été privatisés à
chaque fois sur impulsion de Bruxelles
et ou des États-Unis, bien on se
retrouve à retrouver des ressources
qu'on va pouvoir investir dans les
services publics qui vont pouvoir
alléger la la dette mais aussi la
facture des Français
renforcer les français pour qu'ils aient
au moins une prospective digne de ce
mais là je pense pas que ce soit la
faute du CADOC qui n'a pas été impliquée
dans dans dans ces questions là c'est
Ber c'est Bercy et en réalité je pense
pas que Bercy a commis une forfaiture.
Je pense pas que ce soit les les haut
fonctionnaires. C'est vraiment la la le
responsable politique exactement comme
avec le CICE Jérôme Kusac et Macron
quand même les deux l'ont monté
ensemble. On rend un service à X et Y
nous soutient.
Venezuela le Venezuela, le Groenland,
l'Ukraine, Taiwan.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? On voit le les
arrières cours, les zones d'influence
des blocs se faire sécuriser comme
pourrait faire un débutant dans un jeu
de stratégie type Starcraft.
Pourquoi on l'a pas vu venir ? Pourquoi
on voit l'Union européenne les mains
dans les poches, la bouche ouverte ou
marcher en canard, faire du bruit avec
leur bouche, s'agiter leurs petits bras
et tout le monde sait derrière que quand
Donald Trump va faire une offre
commerciale, si les inuites acceptent,
l'Union européenne va rêver encore tout
de bout. Alors, il y a il y a plusieurs
choses. On l'a pas vu venir, c'est parce
qu'on veut. C'est par exemple dès
octobre 2025, le New York Times révèle
que Donald Trump a autorisé la CIA à
mener des actions sous couverture au
Vené. Donc en fait, c'est annoncé. C'est
d'ailleurs à ce moment-là que Nicolas
Maduro va commencer à tenter une
offensive de charme dans l'espace public
avec les vidéos de lui en train de
danser sur TikTok euh dans le but
d'essayer de s'humaniser pour euh
contrer euh la volonté euh et
déshumaniser à l'inverse les États-Unis
avec leur voie de de de gros moyens
militaires. De façon plus structurelle,
on sait très bien que c'est une zone
dans laquelle les intérêts sont en train
de bouger depuis quelques années.
On se rappelle où est-ce que ça commence
pour la France. Si on parle du point de
vue de la France qui est ce qui nous
intéresse, ça commence avec une
tentative d'exploitation du du pétrole
sur des souches qui ont qui ont qui ont
lieu en Guyane française. Vous vous
souvenez, il y avait eu toute une
discussion sur est-ce que c'était
opportant ou non de le faire.
Finalement, on y renonce. En réalité,
c'est une zone où à côté dans le Guyana,
donc évidemment c'est la même sous
géologique, donc probablement qu'en
réalité on y aurait accès si on faisait
les forages et si on on cherchait dans
la zone réellement ce qui dans nos eaux
territoriales pouvait correspondre. Le
Guyana tout d'un coup découvre
d'immenses ressources et là on va voir
un pas de deux entre les forces
atlantistes et les forces bolivariennes
donc représentées par le Venézuela dans
le but d'essayer de s'approprier ses
ressources. Venézuezuela va pousser
notamment un référendum qui essaie en
gros de s'approprier ses ressources
pétrolifères et qui lui permettent de se
remettre en marche parce qu'il faut pas
oublier ça a été beaucoup discuté ces
derniers temps, mais que l'industrie
pétrolifère vénézuelienne est dans un
très mauvais état. on commençait un peu
à se remettre en marche avec l'aide de
la Chine notamment qui avait créé un
certain nombre d'usines justement qui
avaient pour objectif de traiter et de
pouvoir recevoir le pétrole vénézuulien
qui est très particulier, qui est très
lourd, qui n'est pas facilement
exploitable mais il y a toujours en fait
un partenaire naturel qui est les
États-Unis parce que notamment en
Louisienne, il y a toute une série
d'usines déjà qui sont pas qui sont
capables de traiter ce genre de de
pétrole. Et donc on est dans une
situation où à un moment donné soit on a
un renforcement
de l'axe bolivarien qui lui-même a des
liens avec l'Iran, qui a lui-même a des
liens avec la Chine, qui qui est
fondamentalement anti-impérialiste et
qui en même temps se montre incapable
de de d'exploiter ses ressources et de
protéger ces populations parce que
depuis Maduro, il y a un vrai fondrement
intérieur du régime avec des risques
sécuritaires importants, pas lié au
narcotrafic mais liés très largement
principalement aux vagues migratoires et
toute la déstabilisation que ça ça peut
impliquer. Soit on est sur une reprise
en main un peu un peu véhémante comme
celle qui est en train d'intervenir en
ce moment en violation du droit
international et de tous les principes
mais avec une forme d'intelligence
politique de la part de de Trump qui
consiste à dire on va pas refaire comme
en Irak. C'est quoi la grande erreur de
l'Irak ? même cadre, c'est-à-dire
violation de grand internationale,
volonté de s'approprier des ressources
naturelles,
fausse preuve.
Fausse preuve. Mais quelle est la grande
différence ? En Irak, il y a un projet
idéologique beaucoup plus important
qu'il y a chez chez Trump. Et l'objectif
d'une partie des néoconservateurs de
l'administration Bush n'est pas
seulement le pétrole, c'est aussi le
pétrole, mais c'est aussi un renouveau
de la puissance états-unienne dans le
Moyen-Orient. Et qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
faire ? Ils vont couper la tête au
baassisme, donc à toute la structure de
l'État de Saddam Hussein par vengeance
des pieds de nez de ce qui considérait
être la résistance que Saddam Hussein
leur avait opposé depuis le début des
années 90 et ils vont rendre le pays
ingouvernable. Et donc là en fait, on
est sur une forme de pragmatisme
géopolitique assez assez cynique qui
consiste à dire "On a compris les
leçons, on va pas détruire la structure
de pouvoir du tvise. On va seulement
extraire Maduro, on va l'envoyer aux
États-Unis, mais on va maintenir
bah Delc Rodriguez et et les autres dans
en position de gouverner seulement en
leur imposant nos termes à faute de quoi
on on les fera tomber." Et donc
l'obsession idéologique de
l'administration Trump et de Marco Rubio
notamment, elle est fixée sur Cuba
puisque sur le Venezuela. C'est l'étape
d'après. On parle du Groenland. C'est
aussi une façon de contourner l'effet de
choc que que l'intervention Venezuela
euh a produit. On voit bien que la
Russie et la Chine ne réagissent pas
comme on l'aurait imaginé parce que en
réalité ça les arrange. La Russie par
rapport à l'Ukraine, la Chine par
rapport à Taiwan. il y a tout d'un coup
un argument qui tombe pour le le à leur
opposer et on se retrouve donc dans
cette situation, c'est pas qu'elle est
dangereuse, c'est qu'en fait elle
réactualise complètement l'état du monde
qui et et et la nécessité pour nous de
comprendre que
cette fiction née de l'après-gerre est
achevée, qu'il faut maintenant en tirer
les conséquences. la France n'est pas n
apparaît comme le dindon de la face euh
à bien des égards et pas seulement du
fait de la réaction immédiate de
d'Emmanuel Macron. Et donc on se
retrouve là dans dans une situation
pourquoi je parlais de la Guyan
euh d'une part pour rappeler qu'on est
un acteur de cette région importante.
Que ce soit les Antilles qui sont dans
un état catastrophique, on en parlera
probablement les Antançaises avec le la
question du narcotrafic. On a quand même
eu 70 morts l'année dernière. On a on a
déjà sep morts je pense saufur de ma
part en Guadeloupe depuis le début de
l'année. Donc quasiment un par jour. On
se retrouve dans une situation où on a
une perte complète d'emprise de l'État
sur ses propres territoires. Doublé d'un
manque d'investissement. Là pour le
coup, on lui a en particulier flagrant
avec des niveaux de pauvreté qui sont
qui sont ahurissants. J'y suis allé pour
défendre des militants qui essayaient de
de revendiquer leurs droits. C'est c'est
d'une violence et d'un une structure
encore très coloniale avec que des gens
dépêchés de la métropole. On l'appelle
encore comme ça pour que ce soit sur la
préfecture, sur la police, gendarmerie
plutôt et sur les la magistrature qui
crée un écart avec la population qui qui
est extraordinairement préoccupant et
qui génère en fait des effets quand on
joue à l'autorité mais qu'on en a pas
les moyens. des effets de sécession qui
aujourd'hui dans cette époque prennent
la forme du trafic de stupéfiant et de
la mafia et et d'où en fait une montée
de la violence très très importante. Je
vous parlais en ouverture du fait que
j'avais été en Haïti. C'est important
parce que en Haïti c'est en fait ça
permet de comprendre ce qui se passe au
Venezuela et à quel point les arguments
rhthoriques sur le le trafic de
stupéfiant pour le Vené n'a aucun sens.
En Haïti, on est dans un pays où
aujourd'hui la capitale porte-prce est
contrôlée à 90 % par des gangs. D'accord
? C'est dire qu' en réalité toute la
capitale, sauf le quartier du palais
présidentiel et donc des ambassades est
sous le contrôle des gangs. L'ambassade
de France aujourd'hui ne rend plus ses
services au sein de l'ambassade mais au
sein de la représentation de l'Union
européenne parce qu'elle elle n'est plus
capable de se sécuriser. Donc on est
dans cette situation là et on est un des
rares qui ont encore une représentation
diplomatique qui est restée sur le
terrain. On ne peut plus prendre de vol
depuis l'aéroport de Porteprce de la
capitale. On est obligé, les diplomates
sont obligés d'être convoyés par
hélicoptère à Capaïen au nord pour
ensuite pouvoir ou à Saint-Doming pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir partir. Moi, je
suis quand je suis allé à Haïti,
j'ai rencontré barbecue, le fameux
barbecue dont doncien l'ancien cadre de
la police.
Voilà, de la police haïtienne sur lequel
tant de reportages ont été faits,
spectaculaires.
C'est très intéressant à vivre parce que
donc vous êtes dans un quartier de de
PortoP et on passe vous chercher et vous
traversez une unansland au sein de la
capitale avec des carcasses de voiture
dans tous les sens, une grande sorte
d'autoroute de dans la ville
pour arriver à Delmas à son à son
quartier où à nouveau la vie reprend et
une vie de village parce qu'une vie en
fait complètement
en en autarsie isolée du reste de la
société et dans ce village euh avec ses
gardes du corps, il vous il vous balade,
il vous accueille dans son appartement,
il vous explique que si on l'appelle
barbecue, c'est pas du tout parce qu'il
a fait brûler vivant ses opposants avant
de les manger, mais parce que sa
grand-mère faisait des des barbecues
dans le quartier quand il était gamin et
que du coup la chose est restée. et vous
découvrez en fait un monde où moi la
première question que je me suis posé
c'est
comment est-ce qu'il n'a pas plus peur
de sa sécurité parce qu'à l'heure des
drones
s'il souhaitait véritablement l'éliminer
ce serait d'une facilité déconcertante.
Et en réalité vous êtes dans une
situation où des gens comme lui sont
considérés comme des agents régulateurs.
C'estd que sans lui ce serait pire.
lui à travers sa la coalition de gang
qu'il a qu'il a qu'il a tenté de mettre
en œuvre, il est considéré comme un
facteur de stabilisation où il essaie de
limiter des excès de de fous furieux
plus plus violents encore et et où en
fait vous retrouvez dans un monde où
c'est complètement normalisé la violence
considérée comme la plus barbare, la
plus inhumaine avec des attaques
d'ambulance avec des massacres à ciel
ouvert, avec des viols dans des
conditions que je pourrais même pas
décrire comme comme quelque chose
faisant faisant partie du quotidien. Ça
c'est l'état du monde et c'est un état
grandissant du monde. Et Haïti, c'est au
cœur des Antilles. C'est entre Cuba et
et nos Antilles et c'est une plaque
tournante de la circulation non
seulement de drogues vers les
États-Unis, mais aussi d'armes. On
récupère des armes, on échange des
drogues et ces armesl sont celles qui
vont nous arriver ensuite dans les
Antilles et qui vont permettre tous les
règlements de compte et le développement
du narcotrafic sur notre sur notre
territoire. Ce qui se passe en Ukraine,
ça va être la même chose. De la même
façon qu'en fait toutes toutes les
explosions au début des années 2000 de
la violence du trafic de stupéfiant en
France était lié à la circulation
d'armes suite à la guerre des Balcans
dans les Balcans aujourd'hui on a bien
vu dès dès qu'on a vu dès les premiers
jours
de cette guerre en Ukraine les
distributions à Kief et ailleurs d'AK47
aux populations à l'époque où il pensait
que ça serait une guerre urbaine que les
Russes y arriveraient. On savait
parfaitement qu'il y aurait une fuite
fait la même chose à Caracasse
mais de telle façon de telle façon
qu'aujourd'hui je pense que il y a plus
de mpad en circulation en Ukraine et
notamment dans des réseaux criminels que
nen non les Britanniques ou ou d'autres
forces occidentales. Donc cette cet
ensauvagement du monde, il arrive en
France en France que j'ai découvert
c'est la connexion entre on parle
beaucoup de la DZ mafia, je sais pas si
vous en avez entendu parler qui est
l'une des grandes marques qui est née
aujourd'hui qui regroupe toute une série
en fait de petits réseaux de trafic de
stupéfiants qui sont nés à Marseille qui
sont à partir de Marseille et qui est à
l'origine de une grande partie des morts
des 60 70 morts qu'il y a
à Marseille du fait de règlement de
compte dans une lutte de territoire
qu'il y a eu avec la un autre clan qui
s'appelait Yoda. On parle beaucoup de
des aides mafia parce qu'en fait ils ont
ils ont joué le jeu d'une part de
l'espace public. qu'on les a vu se
montrer comme le TA en son temps avec
des avec les les pardon les visages
couverts et pour essayer de nier qu'ils
avaient été impliqués dans un acte
barbare. Il ils servent en réalité de
couverture à beaucoup de sous-structures
mafieuses. C'est que c'est une sorte de
fiction qui nous permet de d'avoir
l'impression que c'est contrôlé. Mais ce
que j'ai découvert et qui m'a à la fois
sidéré et en même temps indiqué qu'on
basculait dans quelque chose qui était
probablement irrémédiable, on a tous
entendu parler il y a quelques semaines
de du piratage du ministère de
l'intérieur.
Euh donc il y a des gens qui rentrent
dans les bases de données du ministère
de l'intérieur et qui ont accès aux
fiches les plus secrètes et les plus
protégées en théorie qui sont les fiches
Tage FPR. Tage FPR, c'est quoi
traitement des antécédents judiciaires ?
Ça va être la liste, par exemple, de
toutes les personnes qui ont été
impliquées dans une procédure pénale,
soit comme victime, soit comme mise en
cause. Le FPR, c'est le fichier des
personnes recherchées. C'est là où vous
allez avoir par classification diverse
tous ceux qui font l'objet soit d'un
mandat d'arrêt, soit d'une d'une
procédure
qui implique que des actions doivent
être prises contre eux. Euh donc en
réalité, on a arrêté un gamin
quelques semaines après la découverte de
cette fuite et surtout de publication
qu'il y avait sur un forum Bridge Forum
pour essayer de faire croire que la
chose était sous contrôle. Je je vous
laisse terminer mais après je voudrais
qu'on vienne sur la politique Venezuela
Renland.
Mais vous allez voir comment comment ça
se branche. Euh
c'est la personne qu'ils ont arrêté
à grand renfort de médiatique avec le
20h et tout ça d'une part n'était pas
l'auteur des faits et d'autre part les
personnes qui ont commis ces actes-là
sont travaillent avec la DZ.
Et là je pense qu'il faut mesurer ce que
ça veut dire. C'estàd qu'on a des on a
des gamins, on a des hackurs qui sont
parmi les plus brillants de leur
génération,
des pirates, des gens qui hackurs,
crackurs, vous pouvez les appeler comme
vous voulez
et qui rentrent comme comme dans du
beurre dans des systèmes de fichiers
français particulièrement sensibles et
européens. sur ce forum. Par exemple,
hier euh vous aviez le principal
fabricant de d'instruments qui servent
aux fonderies de de puces euh et de de
transistor pardon pour pour les
processeurs et les cartes graphiques.
SLN qui est
l'héritier de Philips au Pays-Bas qui
est notre grande entité souveraine. Bah,
ils se sont fait hacker.
Les AAS, la l'Agence spatiale européenne
s'est fait hacker par ces gamins. Ces
gaminsl sont connectés à ces réseaux
mafieux pour une raison très simple. ces
réseaux mafieux euh trafiquent du
stupéfiant mais après doivent bien
convertir cet argent pour après le
sortir. Ils utilise quoi pour le faire ?
des cryptomonnaies et donc à force de
s'encanailler et d'apprendre les
circuits de blanchiment qui pe pouvaient
être utilisés, ils ont fini par
fréquenter des personnes qui
connaissaient ces hackurs et il y a eu
une jonction qui s'est faite de telle
sorte qu'aujourd'hui ils travaillent
ensemble et ce à quoi on assistait avec
le ministère de l'intérieur, ça a été
une tentative de runsomware de l'État.
Ce qui n'a pas été dit par les médias au
passé, c'était que au même moment où ils
où ils annonçaient ces fuites, ils
demandaient une rençon à l'État français
en échange de la non divulgation des 16
millions de fiches qu'il y avait au
tagge. Alors, il se trouve qu'en
l'espèce, ils avaient pas réussi à
exfiltrer du tout les 16 millions, ils y
avaient accès. Mais qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ? C'est-à-dire qu'en réalité
ces forces mafieuses qui sont dirigées
par des gamins qui pardonnez-moi ont 80
de QI et qui ont qui n'ont
forcément plus que 80 QI.
Non mais c'est là où pour avoir
travaillé regarder la sur quoi repose
leur capacité à dominer dans ces
milieux.
La survie,
l'absence d'inhibition par rapport à la
violence. c'est qui ira le plus loin. Et
en fait, il faut pas de l'intelligence,
il faut de la capacité à écraser l'autre
et à se montrer sans limite et sans
scrupule. Et donc, c'est des gamins de
23, 24, 25 ans qui sont assis sur non
seulement des fortunes liées au trafic
de stupéfiant, mais aussi des fortunes
maintenant liées à leur capacité à
utiliser des pirates, des hackers pour
aller chercher escroquer des grandes
entreprises, des institutions publiques
et qui les soumettent à travers leurs
moyens de coercition. traditionnel, les
tentatives d'enlèvement tout sont
appliquées sur sur ces gamins qui au
début se laissent prendre et puis après
c'est trop tard. Et on a un état
français qui en est réduit à faire de la
figuration, qui en est réduit à faire
des opérations de communication
spectacle consistant à faire arrêter
un gosse près de Limoche pour donner à
croire que la chose est réglée. tandis
que les commanditaires, ceux qui sont
responsables de ces choseslà, mais
surtout ceux qui avaient accès en direct
aux enquêtes en cours,
qui savaient qui se déclarait victime de
leur méfet, quand bien même l'enquête
était encore couverte par le secret au
stade préliminaire ou de l'instruction,
qui savait quand ils étaient visés et
pour quel fait, s'il faisait l'objet
d'un mandat ou pas parce qu'ils avaient
un accès et il continuent à avoir un
accès de l'intérieur à l'intérieur de
ces bases de données eux continuent à
circuler librement, continuent à
voyager, C'est ce que j'ai découvert
sans se faire avoir parce qu'ils ont
accès à les NTS. Ils ont accès aux
moyens qui permettent de fabriquer,
d'authentifier des pièces d'identité en
France et ils sont entre le Maroc, Dubaï
où ils font pas l'objet d'extradition.
On a Darmanin qui après l'assassinat qui
a eu à Marseille du euh de de cette
personne qui était proche de cette
figure de la lutte contre le trafic de
stup, ils ont ils ont ils ont récupéré
90 appartements.
Ils ont je pense que les derniers
chiffres sur le nombre d'extraditions,
c'est 17. C'est pitoyable. On se rend
pas du tout compte du niveau. Et or
c'est pas seulement qu'ils ont beaucoup
d'argent, qu'ils ont pas de scrupule par
rapport à la violence, mais c'est aussi
qu'ils ont infiltré l'État.
On parle beaucoup dans la presse des
greffiers, mais c'est des policiers,
c'est des gendarmes, c'est des
magistrats, c'est des magistrats, c'est
des magistrat qui sont aujourd'hui entre
leurs mains.
C'est quoi vos sources ?
C'est mon travail à la fois comme avocat
et comme enquêteur sur ces questions
depuis depuis longtemps. Parce que en
fait,
comment vous pouvez incriminer les
magistrats ?
Bah parce que j'ai des preuves dans des
dossiers dans lesquels j'ai été
impliqué, j'ai des preuves. J'ai des
preuves de de fuite de d'éléments de
procédures qui ne sont accessibles comme
magistrat, qui ne sont pas entre les
mains d'avocat.
qui ne sont pas entre les mains des
différentes parties. On a quand quand je
représentais ces à cœur cet été qui sont
fait arrêter dans une ospération
spectacle qui était censé mettre fin à
tout ça, c'est dire bravo. Euh qu'est-ce
qu'on découvre ? La fuite intervient
alors qu'ils sont encore en garde à vue.
C'estàd qu'il y a plus d'informations
dans la presse que celle auxquelles on a
accès en tant qu'avocat. Ce qui
d'ailleurs permet de d'assurer une
meilleure défense. Mais et qu'est-ce
qu'on fait une fois qu'on en a
quelques-uns ? On les prend,
on les met dans des prisons où ils sont
immédiatement filmés, immédiatement le
lendemain, le lendemain, il y a un
surveillant qui vient avec un téléphone
pour leur dire continue.
Le lendemain c'est quoi votre source ?
personnel et là c'est dans dans
plusieurs prisons en même temps. c'estd
que c'est c'est des réseaux qui sont
capables en un claquement de doigt à peu
près quelle que soit l'administration
pénitentiaire enfin pardon
l'établissement pénitentiaire dans
lequel vous êtes enfermé de tout de
suite vous signaler que vous êtes entre
leurs mains en prison et de donc vous
transmettre un téléphone pour vous
donner les instructions et ou vous faire
continuer dans la direction qui était la
vôtre jusqu'ici vous et qui ensuite vont
faire circuler vont envoyer à la famille
des vidéos de vous dans la cour filmé
par quelqu'un d'autre pour dire ben
voilà voilà voilà où il est voilà ce
qu'il doit faire Et vous en tant
qu'état, sachant parfaitement que c'est
la situation qui existe au sein de
l'administration bénire, mais profitant
du fait que les Français eux ne sont pas
forcément au courant et que vous pouvez
à travers la presse donner à croire que
ce que vous allez faire peut-être
efficace. C'est-à-dire, j'en ai arrêté
un, vous inquiétez pas, la question de
la fuite au ministère de l'intérieur est
gérée. Non, la question de la fuite au
ministère d'intérieur n'est pas gérée
d'une part parce que rien n'a été
colmaté parce qu'ils ont encore des gens
infiltrés qui leur permettent d'avoir
accès à ces éléments. Vous savez, il y
avait il y avait même pas de double
authentification, c'est un terme
technique, mais c'est c'est vraiment de
base. C'estàd qu'en fait, il fallait il
y avait même pas besoin de la carte pour
accéder à ces fichiers là. Il y a
plusieurs milliers de personnes qui
avaient accès déjà pour commencer.
première problématique et deuxième
problématique euh vous pouviez dire que
vous n'étiez pas sur votre poste de
travail pour une raison x ou y suffisait
de taper un mot de passe.
C'est comme ça que vous
envoyz un mail avec votre mot de passe
avec un
Oui. Mais là là ils ont même
concernant le l'administration amé à
pénitentiaire,
c'est quand même grave ce que vous
balancez. C'estàd que en tant que
source, vous êtes l'unique source.
C'est-à-dire que l'administration
pénitentiaire, telle que je l'entends,
c'est un gruillère corrompu où les
narcos ont des hommes de mains un peu
partout et en fait c'est une succursale
de vous ne parlez pas de l'opération de
Darmanin avec fouille totale de la
des prisons paraît-il que
Mais pourquoi il a pourquoi il a en fait
ils étaient ils étaient au courant avant
ils étaient mis au courant donc il
annonce une fouille massive sur toute la
pénitentiaire avec évidemment par étape,
on peut pas le faire en même temps
partout parce qu'en fait il mobilise des
moyens extérieurs pour accompagner les
agents de l'administration pénitentiaire
pour y aller. Premier problème. Deuxième
problème, ils étaient mis au courant
grâce à leur téléphone et grâce à des
fuites au sein d'administration péncière
les les les détenus eux-mêmes de ce que
la fouille allait arriver à telle date.
Et donc vous avez
Ouais, ils ont trouvé quelques milliers
de téléphones. Ouais, d'accord. Que
dizaines de kilos de médicament. Et ça a
duré combien de temps ? Et qu'est-ce que
ça dit déjà ? Vous voyez le simple fait
qu'il y ait que que qu'il y ait cette
masse de que les conditions de détention
sont tellement exécrables qu'ils sont
obligés de laisser passer des substances
stupéfiantes pour s'édater, apaiser les
les détenus et que bon, il faut bien une
petite connexion internet pour
s'occuper.
C'est 5 6 milliards de chiffres
d'affaires estimés par le trafic de
stupéfiant en France. Donc c'est c'était
au bamo des centaines de millions
d'euros de bénéfices secs au bamo et en
réalité probablement plus. On est on
doit être au-delà du milliard. C'est de
l'argent en cash qui circule
aujourd'hui. Vous pouvez tuer quelqu'un
en France
ça peut baisser jusqu'à 5000 € mais le
plus raisonnable c'est 10000 €. D'accord
? Vous pouvez aujourd'hui vous acheter
des gens qui vont aller soit faire un
enlèvement, soit directement assassiner
quelqu'un pour ces sommesl selon la
sensibilité de la de la cible, ça peut
monter jusqu'à 100000 €. Vous voyez,
c'est à peu près cette ce dispositif là.
C'est des gens qui ont de l'argent à ne
pas savoir quoi en faire.
notamment parce que paradoxalement
l'effort qu'on a fait sur la lutte
contre le blanchiment et la restriction
notamment sur les critères bancaires
pour pour faire rentrer l'argent dans
pour accepter de l'argent qui rentre en
cash dans les institutions bancaires
françaises. On fait qu'il y a eu un
effet de départ très important notamment
à Dubaï où on a en gros aujourd'hui tout
un écosystème financier qui s'est
développé avec des gestionnaires de
fonds euh qui vous permettent de créer
des entreprises euh bidon qui
accueillent l'argent. Puis comme il y a
pas d'imposition euh sur place et assez
peu de contrôle,
imposition sur place mais faible,
extraordinairement faible. Donc en fait
vous retrouvez sur une situation où pour
blanchir de l'argent, c'est vraiment
idéal. C'est que enfin il y a même plus
de de questions à se poser sur le fait
de le faire ou pas. Idem avec le Maroc
qui est quand même un grand pourvoyeur
aujourd'hui de stupéfiant en France de
très loin avec lequel élément qu'on ne
met pas du tout sur la balance dans nos
rapports avec eux. du fait de la
compromission de la corruption de nos
élites dirigeantes qui accueille et
protège euh des grands trafiquants
aujourd'hui. Euh je vais vous donner
l'exemple de quelqu'un qui se fait
surnommer Malsin euh qui est responsable
d'une grande partie des règlements de
compte qu'il y a eu à Saint-Touin sur la
porte de Saint-Touin à Paris dans le
Nord. donc qui a semé la terreur euh
dans sa lutte pour parce que vous savez
il y a ce maire là qui est devenu une
sorte de figure idéale parce qu'il a été
consacré par le Times à Saint-toin. La
réalité c'est qu'il a juste fait
déportter le trafic en bordure de la
ville donc notamment sur la porte de
Saint-Touin et que ça a créé la violence
accrue parce que ça les trafics
empiétait sur des territoires contrôlés
par des bandes différentes. Bien lui par
exemple alors son copain Tagy s'est fait
s'est fait extrater très bien mais lui
reste reste sur place protégé par des
notabilités locales parce qu'il les
alimente
et puis c'est quoi
il a été condamné à 10 ans de prison il
y a il y a il y a 2 ans et il reste en
caval et tout le monde sait qu'il est au
Maroc et il est il est très actif dans
le milieu de la musique française et il
a un label je veux dire et et et tout le
monde trouve ça parfaitement normal et
il est très proche d'un certain nombre
de de de rappeurs français
et et ce n'est seul qui utilise les
sommes extraordinaires qui sont
produites par le rap français
aujourd'hui pour blanchir et pour
injecter de façon on a une explosion,
c'est c'est un détail mais ça a été une
explosion des cachets des des revenus
des des rappeurs qui étaient en grande
partie lié par exemple à ces dispositifs
de blanchiment euh qui font
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des avances
pour des albums qui peuvent monter à
plus de à près de 10 millions d'euros
pour un seul album. Vous voyez, on est
dans une situation qui est incomparable
avec ce qu'on avait connu historiquement
en France dans le milieu de la musique
en général. Et cette gangraine dans
institutionnelle mais aussi évidemment
symbolique parce que du coup en échange
il y a une mise en valeur de ce mode de
vie. Il y a une mise en valeur de ce
type euh de codification avec tous les
termes que qui peuvent être utilisés et
il y a une forme de romantisation
de de ces réseaux et de ces trafics qui
qui sont qui font que et puis après il
faut voir comment ils sont traités.
Quand vous voyez quand vous lisez par
exemple les récits des opérations de
police à Marseille euh lié notamment à à
quand ils sont attaqué un certain nombre
de quartiers nord pour pour essayer de
démanteler les trafics, euh on a un
problème en France
structurel, c'est que les gens ne se
connaissent plus, ne se fréquentent
plus, ne se voient plus. Il y a plus
d'intimité du peuple de France entre
c'est on a eu beaucoup ces débats au
moment où Nicolas Sarkozy a fait
supprimer la police de proximité. Moi,
je pense c'est un problème beaucoup plus
structurel que la question seulement de
la police. C'està-dire que à force de
centraliser les services publics dans
des grosses machines, que ce soit gros
hôpitaux, que ce soit des centres de
sécurité sociale qui ne sont plus des
centres de quartiers comme il y avait
avant, les gens ne ne se fréquent plus.
Et donc sur la police en particulier,
vous avez des PV
qui relatent les opérations qui sont
mises en
moyens. On fait de l'infiltration, on
fait on met des on met des planques, on
met des gens qui sont en train de
prendre des photos tout le temps de tous
les guetteteurs et ils connaissent
personne. Ils savent pas ils savent pas
qu'il surveillent. Voyez, pour eux,
c'est une grande masse obscure. Pourquoi
? Parce qu'ils connaissent pas la cité
sur laquelle ils travaillent. Parce
qu'ils ont pas des gens qui viennent de
là-bas. Et ce qui pourrait se régler en
terme d'identification, vous voyez, des
réseaux de qui fait quoi en quelques
heures juste en parlant. Là, c'est euh
tout d'un coup, on envoie des grands
spécialistes à travers des grandes
agences. Alors là, on vient de créer le
parquet national de la lutte
anticriminalité organisée. On a créé euh
l'ofaste pour remplacer je sais pas
quoi. Et ben, qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
C'est que bah tous les 6 mois, on
découvre que ils font des grandes
opérations comme ça d'infiltration, mais
à la à à l'aveugle, à distance. Et ben,
on se retrouve avec tous les 6 mois des
scandales de corruption majeur avec je
sais pas combien de tonnes de cocaïnes
qui disparaissent et et tout ça de façon
tournante, mais on le voit dans les
dossiers. tout un coup enfin c'est c'est
et donc on a on est dans une situation
où la perte de contrôle elle est réelle
sauf que aujourd'hui
euh c'est ces appareils de pouvoir qui
sont concurrents de l'État. Euh pourquoi
je suis allé sur le terrain ? Pourquoi
je suis allé aussi au Mexique pendant
longtemps à Kouacan ? Tout ça c'est pour
voir aussi à quoi ça ressemble la phase
d'après que ce soit Haïti.
Pris de la drogue ?
Non, enfin j'ai pris des champignons
hallucinogène une fois j'avais je
l'avais raconté parce que c'est naturel
et que c'est pas addictif et que c'est
pas une drogue en soi. C'est un truc
qu'on peut cueillir et mais j'ai jamais
essayé de j'ai très peur de la
dépendance. J'ai une phobie de la
dépendance et et j'essaie de m' j'essaie
de m'en protéger. Euh pourquoi je
parlais de ça ? Parce que donc je suis
allé voir sur le terrain ce qui se
passait au Mexique par exemple. Kuliakan
c'est très intéressant. Euh donc euh
c'est Carartel de Sinaloa euh c'est
vraiment la le cœur euh le euh le le
cœur du du trafic mondial euh en réalité
parce que euh on parle beaucoup du
Fentanil qui
mais ce sont que des passeurs. J'espère
que ça arrive, la matière première
arrive de la Chine. Ça arrive
dans ces zones-là, il y a des labos
fantômes qui qui mettent ça en œuvre et
qui après le transmettent avec toutes
les autres formes de drogue, notamment
celle qui arrive de la cocaïne de la
Colombie via l'Équateur et et ainsi de
suite. Mais pourquoi je parle de ça ?
Parce qu'à Kouacan, par exemple, euh
vous pouvez parfaitement vivre et les
gens vivent parfaitement. C'est une
grande ville et euh
et c'est une ville qui a la
caractéristique du western, c'est tous
les grands western qu'il y avait sur les
méchants et les gentils qui se défiaient
dans la rue avec parfois la rue qui se
vide. C'est exactement ce à quoi vous
assistez encore aujourd'hui. Sauf que
les gamins sont en moto euh et traquent
les flics qui sont en pickup. Et donc
par exemple, les policiers se font
suivre en patrouille par une bande de 6
à 12 gamins qui sont potentiellement des
sicarios pour certains et qui les
pistent de façon à s'assurer des
assassins
des assassins et qui qu' qu'il n'aillent
pas là où il faudrait pas qu'ils aillent
ou que ils ne fassent pas ce qu'il ne
faudrait pas qu'il fassent. Mais vous
vous pouvez, c'est ce qui nous est
arrivé, vous pouvez marcher euh dans la
rue et passer à côté euh de ces gamins
avec leurs armes apparentes et les
policiers évidemment surarmés en face
sans être menacé.
et le quotidien de tous des gens qui
vivent aujourd'hui au Mexique, c'est
c'est une sorte de
de cohabitation avec des appareils
d'état qui sont concurrents. Et tant
qu'il n'y a pas de rupture, typiquement
une de ces opérations de la DEA
spectaculaire où tout d'un coup on va
prendre Chapo ou un autre responsable de
grands trafiquants, ce qui va entraîner
évidemment une reconfiguration et une
lutte sur le terrain entre les
différentes
instances pour pour essayer d'en
profiter. Il y a une forme de stabilité.
Pourquoi ? Parce que ces organes ont
intérêt à cette stabilité, ont intérêt à
ce que ça déborde pas. Et si aujourd'hui
il y a une infiltration silencieuse mais
qu'il n'y a pas trop de menaces
explicites à l'égard d'autorité
politique, à l'égard d'autorité
judiciaire, qu'on qui a une forme de de
oui de cohabitation
de sédation contrôlée
qui c'est ce que j'allais dire qui a
pour intérêt pour les politiciens
de contrôler une partie des territoires
qui autrement remettra en question leur
capacité à la sécurité de l'ensemble des
Français et qui par ailleurs leur permet
de laisser alimenter des millions de
Français qui vivent aujourd'hui en fait
entre ça la consommation qui bat des
records de psychotropes et euh qui qui
vivent en fait leur vie presque à
distance et qui acceptent
la violence du quotidien qui acceptent
les injustices sans se rebeller
notamment par la stupéfiance stupéfiant
psychotrope et et autres autres joyeusé
voilà ou alors un inverse qui tiennent
les rythmes avec une normalisation de la
cocaïne dont les prix ont été divisés
par de en 10 ans et qui est
ça coûte
je pense que on est à 40 50 € alors
qu'on était à 80 il y a il y a il y a 5
ans encore dans mon
le gram le gramme de le gramme de
cocaïne.
La cocaïne consomme combien de grammes ?
Quelqu'un qui est indiqué ?
Alors moi je me suis intéressé quand le
fondateur de En marche Laurent Bigorgne
s'est fait avoir au moment où il avait
tenté de violer sa sa belle sœur et
collaboratrice en glissant de la MDMA
dans son verre. tout ça ? Oui oui, c'est
il était jugé pour alors de façon très
intéressante, il y avait un article du
Canar enchaîné qui montrait comment la
préfecture de police était immédiatement
mobilisée pour le protéger. C'est
intéressant, non ? Vous avez quelqu'un
qui visiblement en fait la la sa belle-
sœur a réussi
à se dépétrer de la situation en
appelant la en parce que elle n'avait
pas encore complètement perdu
conscience. parce qu'elle a compris
qu'il arrivait quelque chose d'étrange.
Elle a réussi à sortir de l'appartement,
à passer un coup de fil pour les
policiers et ça ils sont ils l'ont
arrêté en flagrance. Et donc
de ce que j'ai de ce que j'ai compris
euh cet homme donc qui était le
président de l'Institut Montigne qui est
le plus grandtong français euh libéral
créé par en gros tous les patrons du CAC
40 qui a été euh donc là c'est à son
domicile qui a été domicilié pour la
première fois en marche donc le parti
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2015-216
euh qu'il avait fabriqué j'ai vous
m'aviez invité en 2019 et J'avais
raconté comment on m'avait présenté au
cadavre de Richard Descoins, le le le
directeur de Science Pois à l'époque
dans une sorte de rituel assez étrange
où on essayait en gros de de me faire
intégrer à ce dispositif de pouvoir à
travers à travers la mort. Ce qui
m'avait amené ensuite à être l'étudiant
qui au nom de Science Po lui avait rendu
hommage à Saint-Sulpis. Et bien Laurent
Bigorne était là, voyez, effondré en
larme parce qu'il était censé être le
successeur de Char desc. Donc quelqu à
la tête de scien quelqu'un qui est
vraiment une position structurante et
structurelle de domination au sein de la
lite française. Un passeur entre tous
ces espaces qui était déterminant dans
dans la construction politique
d'Emmanuel Macron se fait arrêter avec
énormément de drogues chez lui derrière
en flagrance. Du coup,
c'est quoi énormément ?
Euh et donc en fait il va il va admettre
c'est c'est pour ça c'est pour ça vous
allez comprendre pourquoi je vous en
parlais. il va admettre qu'il consommait
4 à 5 g de cocaïne par jour.
Donc on donc une consommation qui à
l'époque à 80 € le gram parce que
c'était c'était je pas je vais pas vous
dire d'erreurs dans la dans la date mais
c'était juste avant le confinement dans
mon dans mon souvenir. Ça fait 250 à 300
€ par jour 400 € en fait pardon par
jour. Euh vous multipliez par 30 et vous
comprenez que c'est pas son enfin c'est
pas son salaire à Institut Montigne qui
suffisait à le financer à moins qu'il a
eu des prix de ce micro à ce niveau-là.
Et le canard enchaîné racontait comment
la préfecture s'est mobilisait pour le
protéger pour tenter d'éviter que ça
soit su pour euh ensuite le parquet pour
éviter qu'il y ait des poursuites pour
tentative de viol avec soumission
chimique quand même. Enfin parce que c
évidemment ce qui s'était passé. et il a
été condamné et un peu moins d'un an de
à une peine d'un peu moins d'un anchiné
parce que en en ils ont fait ça en
quelques semaines rapidement pour lui
débarrasser du problème. Donc c'est
aussi l'autre élément c'est que
euh Jean-Luc Mélenchon, il faisait
référence avant-hier dans sa vidéo.
Voilà, il fait un signe pour montrer que
comment vous voulez lutter contre ces
réseaux là quand vous êtes sinon
vous-même dans votre entourage largement
en fait impliqué dans cette consommation
qui s'est complètement banalisée
à Paris en tout cas et dans les élites
en général. C'est pas seulement le bas
peuple he comme ils aiment à le
considérer. On en est loin de là.
Chez les barg pêcheurs, il y en a qui
carburent. Mais ça c'est pour tenir. Là
on est sur en fait une telle dureté au
niveau du travail que il y a comme
pendant très longtemps la gnole a été
la politique pour vous c'est pas de la
dureté.
La politique c'est de la violence mais
c'est de la violence choisie. C'est de
la violence font pas ça pour survivre.
Font ça parce que il y a des appétits de
pouvoir parce que il y a une volonté de
domination qui amène à des comportements
d'ailleurs prédateurs dans les rapports
humains et y compris à leur égard de
même à l'égard d'eux-même. Destructeur à
tous les niveaux. Mais j'ai pas du tout
de pitié à l'égard de ces êtresl.
Revenons à la politique internationale.
Revenons à Donald Trump. Revenons à la
sécurisation des arrières-cours et des
zones d'influence. Sijingping, Taiwan,
la mer de Chine avec des îles en béton
un peu partout.
Vladimir Poutin qui est pas d'accord que
l'Ukraine aille rejoindre l'Europe,
l'Europe qui appelle l'Ukraine, le
Venezuela pour les États-Unis et
d'autres zones d'influence que ce soit
de pêche, de pétrole, de ressources
calorifiques. En général,
voit trois blocs se dessiner. L'Europe
totalement évincée à la ramasse avec des
cadres et des huiles censées anticipé,
prédire, prévoir, appelez ça comme vous
voulez, raconter
n'importe quoi depuis 4 ans qui n'avait
pas anticipé le conflit bien avant le
début de la guerre. Qu'est-ce qui se
passe ? C'est la fin de partie. On gagne
du temps, on dépose l' on dépaisse
l'Europe
pour pouvoir se réarmer. On voit les
Allemands une économie hyper énergie
énergivore, vouloir faire de la tête,
relancer son industrie sans énergie bon
marché et à coup de milliers de
milliards pour pouvoir se réarmer. La
Russie qui commence à s'énerver, tout le
monde s'énerve. On va où Ron Branco ? Le
monde va où ? L'Europe va où ? Et la
France va où ? La France n'a
je vais faire une petite incise mais qui
va permettre de répondre parce que vous
parlez de la volonté d'investissement
technologique de l'Allemagne et de
conversion de son de son industrie. Euh
ça me permet quand même de clore ce que
je disais sur les sur sur les gamins,
mais c'est c'est ça, vous allez voir la
la pour pourquoi c'est lié. Euh je tiens
à rappeler quand même qu'on était censé
de la start-up nation et qu'en fait on a
engraissé euh des
c'est un autre nom chez nous.
Euh
ça s'appelle l'élevage du ara de la
licorne royale.
Ouais. Et moi, moi j'appelle ça euh
l'engraissage de fils de bourge euh qui
ont récupéré des subventions euh et des
financements publics de façon massive
euh et des et par ailleurs de aussi des
plus joli quand même le de la
Oui, c'est plus c'est moins vulgaire, je
je vous l'accorde et aussi de l'accès du
crédit parce que évidemment avec la BPI
et tout ça qui se portait garant de de
tous leur projet, ça a donné quoi ? Ça a
donné Soraré qui est aujourd'hui en
cessation de paiement les petits
asticos. Non non, c'est
Ah non, les réacteurs nucléaires.
Non non, c'est encore pire. Non, vas-y,
vas-y. C'est les cartes Panini en ligne.
Ah,
la start-up la plus valorisée de France,
plusieurs milliards grâce à à Xavinel et
compagnie pour faire des cartes Panini
en ligne et ils ont réussi à faire
croire que c'était l'avenir l'avenir de
la nation. Donc, on a des escrocs en
fait
qui ont récupéré des sommes
des entrepreneurs qui essayent de faire
des projets,
des escrocs qui ont gagné des qui ont
gagné des fortunes,
sont pas là pour se défendre
et qui nous ont fait perdre à nous en
tant que nation. la capacité à investir
dans des secteurs critiques. tirer ça
le fait que ce soit les escrocs
non votre qualificatif
le fait que
ils sont plantés
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que comment
est-ce que vous qualifiez
le fait
pour poser des questions
de lever des milliards d'euros
ils ont pas levé des milliards
pardon des centaines de millions d'euros
pour atteindre des valorisations de
plusieurs milliards d'euros euh en
prétendant que enfin en présentant comme
business model le fait de vendre
des cartes panini virtuelles grâce à des
tokens liés à la à la à la blockchain
donc qui permettait d'assurer que
c'était unique et donc la la valeur de
votre actif c'était lié au fait que vous
aviez un petit code à côté de votre
carte Panini
virtuelle he vous avez même pas droit à
une copie et qui et en gros en réalité
ce qu'il proposait c'était la création
d'un marché spéculatif qui aurait permis
de faire du blanchiment c'estàd qu'en
réalité
c'est votre interprétation
oui mais mettez de côté mon
interprétation ça reste une escroquerie
Parce que votre interprétation
quelle est la valeur créée par ce
commerce ?
L'idée,
je me fais l'avocat du diable. Le
l'idée, le concept,
c'est des escrocs.
Non, je suis pas d'accord. Il faut pas
qualifier les gens comme ça dans le
meilleur. d'ailleurs défendu reçu par
Emmanuel Macron mais en valeur parmanuel
vous pouvez dire que ils se sont plantés
que le marché ou la start-up n'a pas
trouvé son public scandale
que l'étude n'a pas
c'est un scandale et pour moi c'est
pasin que que tous ces gens-là
c'est votre point de vue
a été a été mis en lumière par Xaviniel
Emmanuel Macron lors de sa première
sortie après son élection après qu'il y
soit allé une première fois à la station
F euh lors de ce discours où il a parlé
de ceux qui ne sont rien. Voyez, ce
complexe de supériorité de classe qui
qui faisait qu'il pensait qu'ils
allaient inventer réinventer le monde
mais sans avoir aucune idée de quoi ou
comment et qui en réalité ne les ont
fait que des siphonneurs d'argent sans
avoir rien généré pour le prochain. Rien
généré qui qui à aucun parce qu'ils
n'ont à moment pensé de façon
structurelle, systémique. En fait, je
pense que les gens, les bonnes personnes
pensent de façon générale et
structurante. C'est-à-dire pourquoi ?
parce qu'ils essayent d'inscrire leur
action dans un écosystème qui produise
du coup des conséquences positives. Ces
gens-là n'ont pas pensé comme ça le les
les éleveurs d'astico.
Oui.
Bon 600 millions d'euros.
Ouais.
Ça a pas trouvé son public.
Ouais. Mais c'est quand même une une
idée ou
qui est dans le qui est trop peut-être
trop en avance sur son temps.
Le marché de la protéine.
Bah c'est sûr que oui voilà par rapport
à votre marotte sur la protéine, c'est
sûr que là on ça pourrait s'insérer dans
votre logiciel ou un peu comme la viande
de synthèse. Vi syne.
Ah ça vous ça vous plaît pas des asticos
? Oui mais pas ça reste naturel.
bien frit, sa croque en petit chips.
Ouais.
Avec surtout des trucs pour cacher
l'odeur. Euh ça peut passer.
Mais c'était quand même une idée qui
était précurseur qui n'a pas trouvé son
marché et son public.
Hm.
Des escrocs.
Non, je peux pas vous laisser.
Et donc on est dans une situation où où
en fait
les escrocs ça,
on est dans un pays qui a quand même
Ja Blamon, fondateur du programme
spatial français décédé en 2020 pendant
le Covid. On avait cette discussion à
partir de 2013 sur la protéine animale.
Il a même été rencontré le cardinal noir
au Vatican pour parler au pape pour dire
dites à vos oilles d'arrêter de manger
des protéines de bœuf et passer à autre
chose. Bon, il a pas rencontré son
public non plus
mais c'est il est il était en avance. Il
va là, il va avoir droit à à [rires]
il est en retard sur l'histoire parce
que si le mercur passe comme le saut de
notre gouvernement, on va avoir droit
notre dose de de bœuf et de viande sous
hormone en plus qui qui va mettre à bas
les projets d'asticau qui rester la la
glande de ma mère. C'est [rires]
Oui, on va être tous très heureux à ce
niveaul. Non, mais on est tous les
grands projets industriels que la France
aurait pu porter avec cet argent, vous
voyez, avec tout l'argent que d'autres
escroc pour le coup là, je maintiens ont
dans le dans la pr tentative de
privatisation des réseaux de
distribution d'électricité, de
commercialisation parce que c'est même
pas ça euh aujourd'hui avec la mise en
concurrence sur les trains euh était ma
question.
Donc [rires]
tu fais tomberin mais je commence à
m'énerver là. Donc la question sur la
sécurisation. Oui. Alors donc je vous
parlais de de la start-up nation pour
revenir à C'est ça en fait. Non non si
si on donc on reprend
startup nation. On était censé de la
start-up nation. Bon déjà
on était censé à les zones d'influence.
Ouais. Mais
où va la France ? Où va l'Europe ?
Comment comment on va faire ? Est-ce que
les Danois vont se mettre à mettre des
chap et faire glou glou glou auprès de
Vladimir Poutine en disant "Tu es moins
pire que Trump donc on va faire une
coalition contre Trump. Est-ce que Trump
n'est pas en train de pousser les
Européens à se réconcilier correctement
avec Poutine et faire un bloc
d'équilibre ?
Mais donc on parle de la nation. La
France c'est face à une escroquerie
actuelle qui est euh la start-up nation
qui fait queon n'est même pas foutu de
se protéger de gamins de 16 ans qui
pirate nos fichiers les puissen cibles
et toutes nos institutions. C'est parce
que c'est la fin d'un monde. Et une
escroquerie que je considère alternative
qui est celle qui est proposée portée
aujourd'hui par par la gauche parce que
l'extrême droite n'a pas de projet
différent. En tout cas, le Assemblée
nationale n'a pas de projet différent de
celui de la Macronie. Et une autre
escroquerie pour moi qui est celle de la
gauche que j'appelle
l'immigration.
Non. Oui, je parlais économiquement.
Non. Et même sur migration, c'est faux
de prétendre qu'il y a une différence
parce qu'en réalité dès le moment qu'on
reste au sein de l'Union européenne, il
n'y a pas de possibilité d'une politique
migratoire fondamentalement différente
de de l'actuelle. Et donc la gauche Zara
qui qui en fait propose juste plus de
consommation euh pour maintenir le
système économique actuel. C'est-à-dire
qu'en gros, il propose d'injecter de
l'argent qui va fuir tout de suite vers
l'étranger pour continuer à à consommer
des produits qui sont fabriqués en
Chine, du textile qui est fabriqué au
Bangladesh par nos esclaves préférés.
Donc ça c'est les escroqueries. Or, tant
qu'on reste dans des dispositifs
d'escroquerie similaires, la France ne
peut pas exister en tant que nation.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'elle elle ne peut
pas porter sa puissance. Elle ne veut
pas la projeter.
Moi, je c'est on propose évidemment
d'office, c'est-à-dire la possibilité
pour le peuple de reprendre la parole
qu'on lui a volé en 2005. euh qui est
sur son appartenance ou non à l'Union
européenne telle qu'elle existe. Or
l'Union européenne telle qu'elle existe,
qu'est-ce que ça donne ? Ça donne
Vanerleyen face à Trump quand on il nous
impose de façon unilatérale des droits
de douanes notre incapacité
à y répondre et notre incapacité y
répondre d'une part par absence de
volonté commune parce qu'on n'est pas
une entité politique et économique
commune et d'autre part parce qu'il faut
des mois pour se mettre d'accord parce
qu'on est à 27 dans une même table et
avec des intérêts qui sont divergents
par définition corrompu.
Mais là à ce niveau-là, c'est c'est même
plus de la question une question de la
corruption. Quand vous avez euh euh
notre milliard qui
Non, mais quand quand vous avez notre
ministre des affaires étrangères euh au
sein de l'Union européenne qui vient
d'un pays d'un petit pays de l'Est, il
faut pas s'étonner quel biais euh sur la
question du conflit russo-rainien qui ne
correspond pas du tout, voilà, qui ne
correspond pas du tout à la perspective
qui est la nôtre en tant que français.
Nous, on lui a trouvé un petit nom et il
faut pas Allez-y. [rires]
Dis donc, vous êtes revenu des vacances
avec beaucoup de
Karen.
Ah, très gentil. Bravo. Je laisse je
laisse apprécier au public.
Ça vient des États-Unis, hein.
H
on reprend notre sérieux. Donc,
moi j'attends toujours la sécurisation
des zones d'influence.
Donc, on a on n pas on n pas de capacité
à exprimer une volonté en propre.
D'accord. Et en fait, on court derrière
euh comme des petits chiens derrière
leur maîtres, les grandes sphères
d'influence en espérant leur plaire,
leur complaire et donc continuer à avoir
accès à une petite part du gâteau. Le
Venezuela, c'est ça, c'est euh "Ah, il
ouvre une petite ouverture au Venezuela,
on va peut-être pouvoir caler total.
Donc on se met derrière et on va un peu
plus loin, un peu plus vite que ce qu'il
aurait fallu. On se retrouve à nu avec
le Venus qui dit bye bye. Vous aurez pu
vous pourrez plus compter sur nous pour
les prochaines années. On
a pas pris de vacances hein pour info.
Hm, j'en doute.
Bah [rires]
je vous le souhaite en tout cas parce
que l'époque va être dure et l'année va
être va être violente. Donc la France
est perdue et bloquée dans un projet
continental. français qui consistait à
s'insérer et à renforcer sa force.
C'était l'intention d'Emmanuel Macron et
noncé dans le discours de la Sorbonne
des 2017 dans mon souvenir octobre 2017
ou 2018 à vérifier et qui consistait en
fait à faire à faire l'Europe puissance,
il appelait ça comme ça, et à donner à
la France une classe cardinale au sein
de cette institution, de ces
institutions euh sans pour autant même
essayer de d'y défendre le français.
Rappelons que le Royaume-Uni enfin
pardon que l'anglais et la langue
dominante dans l'Union européenne alors
que le Royaume-Uni est sorti et qu'à
part l'Irlande, on a plus un pays qui
qui parle anglais dans dans cette dans
dans
cette institution à 27. Donc on est dans
une perspective de courte vue qui nous
met toujours plus en tension avec euh
les grands blocs parce que en réalité on
cherche à exister par nous-même mais
sans avoir une idée de pourquoi ou dans
quelle direction. Donc on est vu comme
des provocateurs arrogants un peu
énervants et gênants. Ce qui explique la
dernière sortie de Vladimir Poutine par
rapport à la coalition des volontaires
où il annonce qu'en gros la disposition
c'est c'est là où on voit c'estàd que ce
qu'il acceptait il y a encore quelques
mois maintenant c'est fini. Donc pour il
vient d'annoncer que la
présence de soldats provenant de cette
coalition sur le sol ukrainien serait
considéré comme un acte de guerre et il
serait des des cibles légitimes.
Donc bye bye parce que évidemment on va
pas se mettre dans cette position là.
Donc toute l'agitation proposée par
Emmanuel Macron depuis quelques mois sur
sur ce qui lui apparaissait comme la
nouvelle solution pour avoir de la
France une position
dominante sur cette question, sur ce sur
cette zone territoriale et bien c'est
fondant. Donc il faut commencer à
réfléchir en terme géopolitique. Vous
voyez, il faut pas Moi, la géopolitique
pour moi c'est un peu
et la guerre économique
et la guerre économique qui est qui est
une une des dimensions de de l'analyse
géopolitique. Moi je moi j'ai fait un
master en géopolitique et j'ai beaucoup
de distance par rapport à la
géopolitique parce que c'est une arme de
virtualisation. Vous voyez euh c'est
surtout que c'est en général des
concepts brassés par une bande de pécor.
Oui, c'est ça. Et alors là, on va vous
expliquer que Mckinder a dit qu'il y
avait les puissance navale anglo-saxonne
qui ont une ontologie particulière euh
qui serait différente de celle des puiss
puissances terrestres. Bon, tout ça,
c'est une façon pour les semi-habiles de
se donner l'impression de comprendre
comment fonctionne le monde et de
surtout de le maîtriser. C'est c'est la
c'est l'obsession de la maîtrise et de
la domination. Donc il faut faire
attention. Il y a des milliers de
paramètres qui sont très difficiles à
synthétiser. Je peux vous couper
mais Oui. Allez-y.
C'est demi-habiles.
Oui.
Bon là ça fait 4 ans qu'on voit bien que
c'est les Alors
là non là là c'était même pas les
demies. C'est un crous parce que les
demiabiles c'est ceux qui au moins
essayent d'avoir une théorie
ou qui essayent de maintenir l'illusion.
Oui mais alors c'estd que c'est pas les
Michel Goya et compagnie c'est voyez
c'est les demies sont un peu au-dessus.
Enfin, c'est euh
Non, mais parce que parce que parce que
voilà, [rires]
c'est l'incarnation.
Mais non, gentil avec Michel, c'est un
des seuls qu'on a pas encore banni. Oui,
ben je pense que ce serait très bien que
vous l'invitiez d'ailleurs. Euh ils sont
c'est c'est des c'est des techniciens.
C'estàd qu'en fait ils sont même pas il
y a les théoriciens, c'est pour moi les
demiabiles c'est cela et il y a en
dessous ceux qui pensent par la
technique qui disent "Ah oui, moi je
sais comment fonctionne un régiment et
comment ça se déplace sur le terrain."
Donc je vais vous expliquer la vie. Tout
s'explique à partir de ma maîtrise
technique euh des paramètres locaux euh
d'une euh d'une mobilisation militaire.
Euh au-dessus, mais c'est pas au-dessus
parce qu'en réalité c'est une autre
forme de vanité. Il y a ceux qui
réfléchissent par grands ensembles
théoriques, voilà, avec les les ça va
close vite, ça minder en passant par je
sais pas quoi,
font jamais de terrain
et qui font jamais de terrain et qui se
perdent dans leur virtualisation du
monde et qui surtout deviennent très
rapidement des idéologues
euh euh courtisans, c'est en fait parce
que leur leur seul but
vous parlez de ceux qui se coiffent avec
du pétrolan.
Non non non parce que là il a pas de
rapport à la théorie ce garçon. C'est
plutôt, je pense par exemple en en
Russie,
on va en avoir plusieurs mais ça va de
Dougin enfin par
Oui. Non, c'est des gens qui à un moment
donné vont vont penser en grand bloc
historique, ontologique avec l'essence
des peuples, avec des facteurs
économiques. Ouais. Et après, il y a le
dirigeant politique qui lui est obligé
de composer le réel, vous voyez, qui a
un moment donné se et alors s'il
réfléchit un peu, il essaie d'associer
histoire, économie, géopolitique et donc
en l'occurrence on est c'est quoi la
France aujourd'hui dans le monde là ?
Vous vous êtes en train de vous
chamailler, ça me
J'ai le réalisateur qui dort. [rires]
Oui, d'accord. Il a l'air très attentif
pourtant. Je pense qu'il est plus
intéressé par moi que par la
réalisation.
Non, ça s'appelle hypnotisé. Il fait ça
depuis qu'il est en 6e et il aime bien
avoir un regard fixe et c'est ça le rend
intelligent.
Bon, on pas être chose sérieuse. Non,
non,
on essaie de vous déconcentrer parce que
j'ai toujours pas ma réponse.
Donc, c'est j'allais y venir. C'est quoi
la France dans ce dispositif là ? Par
exemple, l'une des premières critiques
que j'énonce à l'égard d'Emmanuel Macron
sur la position d'Ukraine. Quels sont
nos intérêts géostratégiques sur le
terrain et pour qui nous amène à prendre
cette positionlà ? Qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'on cherche à s'impliquer de cette
façon dans le conflit en cours entre la
Russie et l'Ukraine ? Il y avait pas
d'explication géostratégique ou
géopolitique.
La France aujourd'hui est face à une
situation critique pour une raison très
simple.
On parle beaucoup du danger russe. Les
Danois encore il y a 6 mois disaient "La
seule menace qui existe pour nous c'est
la Russie. Là aujourd'hui ils ont l'air
malins avec les États-Unis qui qui
veulent saisir le Groenland. Nous on
s'est centré sur l'obsession russe où on
se retrouve à arrêter. Il y a une femme
qui s'est faite arrêter il y a quelques
semaines parce qu'elle avait posté des
posters, elle avait mis des posters
autour de l'Arche à Paris.
Elle a peut-être elle a peut-être
financé des gens dans le Donbas et ça
terminait dans l'escarcelle des gens qui
étaient militarisés.
Qu'est-ce que Qu'est-ce qu'elle faisait
et pourquoi est-ce qu'elle a été arrêtée
? Elle elle elle mettait des posters à
droite à gauche qui rappelaient quoi ?
qui rappelait que l'Allemagne avait été
vaincue grâce à la Russie et qu'en
réalité si nous n'étions aujourd'hui
plus sous occupation allemande, c'était
grâce à l'engagement des troupes russes.
Ce qui était quelque chose de très su
jusqu'aux années 60 70 en France et
qu'on a complètement oublié. Bah parce
que celui ceux qui ont pris la maîtrise
du narratif avec tous les films et
Hollywood et et autres, c'est euh c'est
les États-Unis. Donc on on regarde le
monde à travers à travers Spielberg et
donc on a l'impression que c'est le
débarquement qui a qui a changé le
destin de la seconde guerre mondiale.
Donc c'est quelque chose de pas
fondamentalement nocif, c'est un pur
rappel historique. Et ben elle se
retrouve arrêté, poursuivi pour des
histoires d'ingérence au sein de de
l'État et la DGs est très fière d'avoir
fait tomber cette extraordinaire menace
pour l'État tandis qu'elle laisse passer
tout le reste sans aucune difficulté. La
France aujourd'hui, elle a quoi comme
adversité ? Elle a elle a quoi comme
danger structurel ? Et là, le fait que
l'Allemagne
l'Allemagne en 2026 va avoir un budget
militaire deux fois plus important que
le français.
VB.
Grâce à quoi ? Grâce à notre fixation
obsessionnelle sur le conflit
russoau-rainien, on est en train de
réactiver. C'est pas que le peuple
allemand soit ontologiquement menaçant
pour la France. Enfin, on est on pense
même structurellement sur l'histoire
longue. Les francs étaient germains.
Donc, je veux dire euh notre nation est
née de cette hybridation entre nos
territoires et nos et nos cultures. tout
simplement que la la la physique des
puissances fait que quand vous avez une
course à l'armement entre deux grandes
puissances économiques qui sont par
ailleurs en difficulté, qui font face à
une crise politique, à une crise
économique industrielle et qui donc font
face à un mécontentement grandissant de
leur peuple qui aujourd'hui se fixe sur
la question de l'immigration, ce qui est
un purgatoire naturel, vous voyez, de de
la violence interne. on va sur le bouc
émissaire, la figure de l'étranger, mais
qui à un moment donné peut rapidement
basculer sur la figure du voisin et en
l'occurrence de l'allemand,
à un moment donné, on est sur un
aveuglement qui est particulièrement
dangereux et qui nous met en difficulté
parce qu'il va pas y avoir de communauté
de destin entre nos peuples quand on
sera armé jusqu'au dents et qu'on
pensera que notre existence est en jeu
face à face à reconfiguration
géopolitique qui sont en cours. On a
trois dirigeants politiques qui dans les
trois plus grandes nations européennes
sont extraordinairement fragile.
Emmanuel Macron, Mertz, Starmer. Ce sont
des personnes qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas
l'approbation de leur population, qui
sont soit fruits de coalition contre une
nature, soit comme c'est aujourd'hui le
cas en France gouverné par des gens qui
n'ont pas de majorité au Parlement et
qui imposent de facto un pouvoir euh à
leur peuple qui est rejeté et qui
cherchent à travers l'exutoire de la
confrontation géopolitique une
justification à leur maintien au pouvoir
et à leur domination. Et ces gens-là
sont capables de nous amener à des
grandes catastrophes. Ils sont capables
de nous amener à ouvrir des fronts dans
le seul but de se perpétuer au sein du
pouvoir. Et aujourd'hui, or
géostratégiquement la France par rapport
continentalement d'abord
c'est le contrepoids à une Allemagne qui
est perçue comme une menace potentielle
par la Russie. Là encore pour des
facteurs structurels
structurellement par la proximité. Oui,
mais la Pologne
n'a pas l'assise et la puissance
aujourd'hui
encore 10 ans. PB dans 10 ans le PIB ou
le PB Oui, mais le PIB attention c'est
un flux, c'est c'est la production à
instanté. Il y a quand même toute
l'accumulation de richesse qui fait que
quand bien même le PIB à un moment donné
croisse de façon si massive, il y a
encore tout un effet de rattrapage à
mettre en œuvre sur la structure
économique qui reste qui reste en place,
les investissements accumulés sur des
sur des décennies. Mais mais euh à un
moment donné, on va être obligé de
réfléchir non plus d'un point de vue
moral, mais d'un point de vue des des
des dynamique de poids géopolitique pour
dire on est obligé de rétablir un axe
euh franco-russe si on souhaite
stabiliser
euh l'Europe. Voyez ? Alors avant avant
de stabiliser l'Europe avec un axe,
quelles vont être les les conséquences
sur la dette les émissions de dette
française sur les marché quand la jeune
et fringante dette allemande triple A va
débarquer ? Est-ce que nous cette
vieille dette d'un vieux pays
qui s'effondre va être plus sexy, moins
sexy, encore moins sexy ? Est-ce que nos
taux vont augmenter vu la stabilité
politique qui est à l'image des
agriculteurs qui montent prendre Paris ?
Est-ce que si on se refait dégrader
notre note, notre dette va se s'empirer
? Les intérêts de la dette vont
s'empirer et il y a cette dette
allemande toute pimpante de son triple A
pour un un objectif drappé dans
l'étendard de la vertu de la liberté de
ses valeurs européennes.
Qu'est-ce que nous la France on va faire
quand Tata Germanie va nous damer le
pion ? Bah moi je moi je je vais vous
répondre la question de la dette et les
grands équilibres économiques. Mais
juste avant pour finir ce que je disais
la Russie aujourd'hui
insiste
mais parce que elle a tout intérêt
aujourd'hui à s'allier avec les
États-Unis pour écraser l'Europe Russie.
Oui. Ce qu'on voit pas venir,
elle s'allie pas. Ça s'appelle une
alliance de convenance.
Oui mais elle a tout intérêt à pousser
dans cette direction. Ce que je veux
dire c'est que là on est sur
on est trop con pour voir
on a pris voilà on a pris pour acquis le
fait que
ils sont trop cons.
La Russie euh voulait absolument euh
qu'on se remette euh en forme tous dans
un grand festin euh en étant enant à
nouveau euh si possible au détriment de
l'Ukraine. Mais sinon euh tant pis. À un
moment donné les Russes vont se dire
"Mais non mais là je vois en fait
l'équilibre qui est en train de naître.
ça va être beaucoup plus facile de
mettre sous sous chap l'Europe
occidentale sans à chercher de
compromis, sans chercher d'accord parce
que d'une part je le peux parce que
d'autre part c'est dans mon intérêt y
compris en terme prédateur parce que
c'est quoi c'est quoi le niveau de vie
des Russes aujourd'hui ?
Lesquels ? Parce que la Russie c'est
très très grand.
Voilà mais c'est quoi le le le niveau
des retraites en Russie ? Je sais 400
balles de tête 300 balles mais non
c'est la c'est la fameuse
c'est euh c'est c'est très connu en
Russie étais j'étais en Russie en Chine
il a il y a il y a il y a 2 3 mois parce
que justement j'essayé un peu de me
confter
qui a financé comment vous avez été j'ai
suis allé présenter un long métrage que
j'ai réalisé euh qui été payé par ma
alors
en Chine c'était par le festival de
Jazanke qui est un très grand
réalisateur chinois qui nous a qui a
sélectionné le film et en Russie c'était
C'est
soit une fondation privée qui est celle
qui a montré le film, soit nous, je sais
plus s'ils nous ont payé le billet ou
pas, mais on s'est retrouvé dans un
hôtel tr étoiles. Alors, c'était marrant
parce qu'en même temps, il y avait des
influenceurs français qui eux étaient
payés par le régime Ruby sur l'ongle et
qui faisaient des vidéos dans leur
chambre d'hôtel 5 étoiles. Ouais. Ouais.
Parce qu'il faisaient des vidéos en même
temps. Je suis tombé dessus un peu
étonné. Euh euh invité s de conférence
débile parce que les les Russes
contrairement à ce qu'on pense sont pas
les plus fins de de la terre en ce qui
concerne le leur stratégie d'influence.
Et donc ils invitent un un de ces
gars-là qui est en train d'expliquer
dans la vidéo pour essayer de faire
plaisir à ceux qui l'ont invité que les
les eaux de la Mosva sont complètement
transparentes et qu'ils ont pas eu
besoin de milliards pour pour pour les
nettoyer comme la scène alors que bon
elles étaient plus dégueulasse encore
que que c'est la scène qui était là pour
m'en rendre compte. Et donc on présente
le film qui a un film d'ailleurs sur
l'instrumentalisation de la justice.
C'était très intéressant de pouvoir le
montrer euh en Russie en Chine. Suivi
euh non.
Vous avez passé le dératiseur dans votre
chambre ?
Non, j'ai pas j'ai pas cherché et mais
j'ai pas été approché. J'ai rencontré
des gens notamment des des opposants, un
avocat très important qui travaille avec
le Parti communiste qui reste une force
sociale importante qui
défend notamment Audalsov qui vient
d'être enfermé pour pour 6 ans et je
pense que c'est important de d'en parler
parce que même Mélenchon l'a abandonné
considérant que
en fait c'était son token et il était
plus utilisable par lui donc donc il a
un peu mis de côté. Donc on va essayer
de d'ailleurs de faire quelque chose
avec cet avocat. Et pourquoi je vous en
parlais ? Parce que donc il y a en
Russie euh il faut quand même aussi
l'avoir à l'esprit. J'ai essayé de
sortir de Moscou pour pas laisser avoir
par en effet cette apparence de
modernité ou c'est on sent que les
sanctions n'ont pas d'effet sur la
classe moyenne et supérieur si ce n'est
une relative perte de pouvoir d'achat
pour les classes moyennes mais sans
changement de type de vie. Donc il y a
toujours autant de voitures allemandes
et étrangères de façon générale.
Plus de voitures chinoises.
Oui, mais pas tant que c'est que en fait
ça c'est ça s'est vraiment installé.
C'est on continue à voir des des
Porsches dans les étales comme étant la
voiture de référence à acheter pour les
classes les plus les plus aisées et de
façon générale une ville qui a perdu de
sa de sa vivacité par rapport à celle
que j'ai connu mais où on sent pas
directement la guerre. Ce qui est assez
classique, c'estàd que quand en général
quand vous êtes à 200 300 km du front et
dans une capitale d'un pays euh il y a
pas du tout d'effet immédiat sur dans le
perçu en fait.
Frapp ukrainienne quand vous étiez sur
place.
Non non pas du tout. Et puis j'ai pu
visiter le cremelin. C'estd qu'il y a
encore des ordes de touristes. C'est que
vous pouvez visiter comme touriste le
cremelin. Il y a c'est pas fermé au
public. que vous avez des gens qui
reviennent du front qui qui sont là
parce que il y a un grand monument au
mort avec les grandes batailles de
l'histoire de la Russie en face du du
Kremelin et vous avez vous avez pas du
tout une un état de mais je pense que
Kiev c'est pareil. Je pense qu'en fait
on est sur des situations où où pour peu
à quelques centaines de kilomètres du
front il y a une sorte d'apparence de
normalité qui continue de dominer très
importante. Et
Kief Kief et Moscou il y a quand même
des drones qui qui tabassent.
Ouais ponctuellement. Mais c'est très
rare en fait, on se rend pas compte en
terme par rapport à la quotidienneté.
C'est très rare. C'est quelque chose
avec lequel on peut parfaitement vivre
et auquel on peut parfaitement euh
parfaitement s'habituer. Euh euh et par
contre, c'est vrai que par rapport à la
Chine euh il y a eu un il y a il y a il
y a il y a une inquiétude plus
importante pendant cette période par
rapport à l'expression publique. C'estàd
que vous sentez euh alors c'était
marrant parce que en Chine j'ai parlé de
Chijin Ping dans la conférence de presse
que j'ai donné pour mon film et alors
j'ai vu tout le monde tout d'un coup se
se fermer parce qu'on ne dit pas son
nom. C'était pas le contenu qui posait
le problème, c'est le fait que c'est
devenu un peu comme le souverain dans
les anciens régimes. On ne prononce pas
directement son nom dans l'espace
public, il vaut mieux pas. Mais j'ai dit
quoi ? On dit quoi ? On on contourne
alors je me souviens plus en anglais
qu'est-ce que la façon dont il l'avait
traduit sur ce qui bah il fallait dire
le chef d'état ou le président du
du parti du PCC. Mais par contre à
Shangï, je me suis retrouvé avec des
universitaires qui m'avaient invité à la
faille. J'ai donné un cours sur l'état
de droit à Pékin, d'ailleurs à
l'université. Mais à Shanghai euh une
critique d'une violence mais radicale à
l'égard du Parti communiste avec en
train de d'enser Ayek devant les
étudiants alors que comme on imagine
bien c'est pas les endroits les moins
surveillés qui soient les universités et
en particulier les vos étudiants avoir
un rapport de confiance sur ce qu'ils
vont dire pas dire de vous et cetera
dans le régime censé au au bénéfice de
donc et pour l'économie en fait il s le
néolibéralisme est très dominant dans
les élites intellectuelles
libéralisme kénienne
non non antikenésienquen donc vraiment
c'est l'état nazique aïec l'état minimal
vraiment une sorte de de radicalité anti
antiétatist
voilà c'est ça et une critique très très
ouverte du parti communiste et pas du
tout cette
il y a il y a a en fait j'ai compris
là-bas qu'il y avait un énorme effort de
propagande sur le crédit social par
exemple mais un effort construit je
pense qu'il y a vraiment des agences qui
essayent de faire croire qu'il y a un
monde fondamentalement différent du n
are en partie pour nous faire oublier
qu'on est dans des pays qui sont très
surveillés et où en fait l'espace et
liberté n'est pas si ample que ça et
donc le
faire sauter votre compte banque pour
le votre compte sur réseaux sociaux vos
inter réseaux sociaux moi j'ai moi j'ai
pas le droit d'ouvrir un un compte en
banque je me suis je me fais refuser
hein aujourd'hui parce que je suis
personnalité surveillé traque fin depuis
la Wikileak depuis 10 ans depuis que
j'ai 25 ans et c'est pas parce que j'ai
des mago quelque part c'est juste
d'office Vous êtes placé sur une liste,
on parle des sanctions européennes qu'il
y a contre un certain nombre aujourd'hui
de citoyens parce qu'ils ont pris des
positions qui étaient contraires à
celles de de l'Union européenne. Et donc
cette obsession de la surveillance, on
oublie en fait que ces régimesl une fois
qu'ils sont installés, ils ont pas
besoin d'être dans une répression
quotidienne. L'effet signal,
il est déjà transmis. Et donc en fait
les populations apprennent à contourner
l'obstacle, à contourner, c'est un peu
l'exemple sous l'Union soviétique euh
des blagues, les fameuses blagues russes
sur le régime, sur Crochef, sur où en
fait par l'humour par exemple, on
faisait de la politique sans sans parler
directement
de politique. Et donc dans ces régimes
là, par exemple, mon film est sur
l'affaire de Gill de Ray sur donc
c'était un compagnon d'armes de Jean
Dark qui a été et qui est un film
d'ailleurs de facto censuré en France.
D'ailleurs, on peut pas le montrer dans
ce pays. Pourquoi ? parce que parce que
on est je suis devenu complètement
fréquentable au sein d'une petite élite
parisienne et que le sujet est radical
parce qu'il interroge la question des
panique morale notamment avec les chasse
aux sorcières et les la répétition de
ces mécaniques à travers les phénomènes
type mitou aujourd'hui en France en
France et dans l'Europe occidentale et
enfin pardon dans le monde occidental et
donc ce film là
Gill de c'est la figure qui a inspiré
Barbe Bleue
et la France l'Europe
voilà donc le taux de retraite on va y
revenir mais enfin tout est lié le taux
de retraite enfin pardon les retraites
en Russie, il y a il y a il y a il y a a
y il y a en fait on les appelle les la
génération 16000 roubl c'est 160 €. Donc
vous dès que vous sortez de Moscou
avoir un salaire à l'équivalent de 300 €
c'est la norme. Vous voyez c'est ça se
retrouve dans une situation. Or, à
l'inverse, euh les rémunérations pour
partir au front extraordinairement
élevées et euh les compensations en cas
de blessures, en cas de mort sont
extraordinairement élevées et la prise
en charge des des euh des euh des
militaires une fois qu'il qu' qu'il sont
démobilisés estelle est-elle aussi
particulièrement soignée par le régime.
Par contre, une fois vous rentrez, vous
sortez plus. Il y a il y a un piège dans
lequel vous rentrez où en fait on vous
lâche plus. Pourquoi ? Parce que la
grande obsession de Poutine aujourd'hui,
c'est d'éviter la conscription.
C'est que quand il y a eu une tentative
de conscription il y a un peu plus il y
a 2 ans dans mon souvenir, il y a
comment il y a eu un début de révolte
dans une population qui aujourd'hui est
résignée par rapport au conflit, qui
n'est pas en adhésion, qui est résigné
mais qui quelque part le tolère, le
supporte, supporte d'être dans cette
mise en tension avec toutes les
conséquences que ça a sur le la capacité
à avoir du pouvoir d'achat et ainsi de
suite. Mais dès le moment qu' a il y a
eu des épisodes similaires à ceux qu'on
connaît en Ukraine avec les résistances
toujours croissantes d'ailleurs qui en
Ukraine, là il y a eu une un début de
menace à l'égard du pouvoir qui a dû
reculer et qui du coup se retrouve en
fait à à en difficulté par rapport à ces
fondamentaux économiques parce que ça
coûte très cher de de passer autrement
que par la conscription et qui est
obligé d'aller chercher des gamins au
fin fond des villages en leur promettant
que ça durera 15 ans et en réalité il se
retrouve pris pour pour un certain
nombre d'années.
Pour pourquoi est-ce que je parle de ça
? Parce que tant en Russie qu'en Chine
et surtout en Chine d'ailleurs
paradoxalement, ce qu'on sent que c'est
pas du tout évident
la permanence du pouvoir dans ces
territoires, leur capacité à dominer de
tels espaces, de telles masses de
population avec des moyens qui sont
encore limités, que ce soit les uns à
cause de l'effondrement de l'URSS et
toutes les conséquences qu'il y a eu
après le pillage des populations pendant
des décennies ou en Chine parce que
c'est un pays qui sort d'une pauvreté
massive.
En Chine, j'ai compris au centre à
Shanghaiï au centre, vous avez ces
images qu'on voit partout et que tous
les propagandistes
diffuse de grande centre urbain hyper
modernes avec des drones partout, avec
des grands
avec des tours immenses et ainsi de
suite. Et en fait c'est ces ces forces
là architectonique et même en terme de
de richesse ont pour vocation à draîner
les énergies du reste du pays et à leur
dire voilà il y a un avenir dans le pays
et cet avenir c'est celui-là vous pouvez
y accéder mais la réalité des villes
parce que j'ai du coup j'ai pris le
temps de voyager
c'est monstrueux ce sont des kilomètres
et des kilomètres de tour identique
dans une grisaille et dans une absence
de c'est en fait ces gens vivent encore
très mal et pour accepter leur destin,
il leur faut à la fois cet horizon
fantasmatique incarné par les grands
centres urbains, mais aussi un pouvoir
qui leur laisse une certaine marge et
qui donc est vraiment à très très
éloigné de cette sorte de contrôle
social hyper fin queon présume quand on
est à l'extérieur. pas du tout
la
qui tu t'énerves toi
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
Non non donc je sais pas je vais parler
parce que
j'espère j'espère que notre ami va nous
remettre un briquet un briquet
je sais pas j'ai le radiateur qui avait
enlevé son casque.
Donc le je j'en profite pour euh vous
poser une question et revenir pour faire
une petite diversion. Euh ah il avait
plus de pile.
Donc Tipi, n'oubliez pas de nous
soutenir sur Tipi parce que on a besoin
de changer les piles et de trouver euh
un caméraman et un réalisateur qui ne
dorme pas.
Donc soutenez-nous sur
on a besoin
de vous pour C'est bon, le son est
revenu. Tu peux remettre ton casque. On
a besoin de vous pour pouvoir la
stabilité, l'indépendance et produire du
bon contenu.
Est-ce que le caméraman ou l'ingénieur
du son peuvent me certifier que tout est
revenu ? Ran, tu me dis un petit mot ?
Ouais.
Peux parler du port chinois si vous
voulez qui é une grande obsession
d'Emmanuel Macron. Tu casque avant que
je te fasse passer par la fenêtre.
[rires]
Et donc la France, l'Europe, comment
elle doit se positionner ? La peur, elle
doit pas être dans le fantasme et dans
la panique à l'égard de ces grands
blocs. Ça c'est le premier point.
D'ailleurs, la il faut il faut pas
oublier que les États-Unis aussi sont
font face à une forme de décomposition
partielle. Euh si Trump parle beaucoup
du trafic de drogue en ce qui concerne
le Venezuela, c'est parce qu'il fait
face à une crise sociale majeure avec le
Fentan Hill et une désagrégation majeure
d'une part de la société qui est
complètement crispé autour des questions
identitaires, migratoires et autres.
Donc on est on est sur une situation où
on manque pas d'avantage. C'est juste
qu'en fait on on on fait enfin pardon de
de de points de force, sauf qu'on on
sort d'une de 10 20 30 ans d'absence de
de direction politique et d'absence
d'articulation entre notre puissance
économique industrielle et l'État. C'est
qu'on a une sorte de dépessage de l'État
qui a commencé les années 80 avec les
privatisations ordonnées par la droite
accompagné de cette politique de
stimulus kinésienne par la gauche qui a
qui nous a saigné parce qu'on en fait on
on finançait de façon massive
l'endormissement des populations par une
un accroissement de tout ce qui est
minim sociaux standard de vie injecté au
lieu de productif et lié à la à la
vigueur économique. et de l'autre côté
on on vendait les les trésors nationaux
en tout cas voir pire on les laissait
piller et donc on on a perdu notamment
dans la technologie et autres une série
d'appuis qu'on avait avec des grandes
entreprises que ce soit le CATEL et
autres. Donc OK euh aujourd'hui on peut
se relancer sans trop de difficultés
mais par contre il faut relever le
niveau d'exigence de façon massive se
relancer comment là sans trop de
difficulté on n pas d'énergie on n pas
d' gr
on a de l'énergie comment ça on n'a pas
d'énergie
on a encore une puissance agricole
exportatrice de limite mais on l'a
encore. Ouais ouais bien sûr. Oui oui.
Bah c'est sûr que si on se met en
c'est mercour qui nous vient nous casser
les
engrais les engrais qui coûtent plus
cher parce que comme on est fâché avec
nos copains les russes bah ça devient
compliqué.
Le pétrole, on apporte beaucoup.
Vous voulez qu'on parle des problèmes ?
On peut en parler hein. L'Afrique enfin
l'Afrique qui a qui a pris facilement.
Moi, je pense que si. Je pense qu'on a
vraiment une capacité encore
aujourd'hui. C'est quoi ? C'est
3300 milliards de dettes, on paye des
intérêts journaliers de dette
deux fois pratiquement deux fois
supérieur à notre consommation
énergétique réelle. Oui, mais sauf que
ces intérêts de dette en terme absolu
euh enfin en PPA ont pas largement
évolué ces 20 dernières années.
Évaluer dans quel sens ?
Bah qui ils sont restés relativement
stables euh du fait du fait de la perte
d'intérêt euh
Combien on payé d'intérêt de dette ?
Ben vous l' vous l'avez dit vous-même,
c'est 300 milliards. Attendez, c'est Non
non non non. On est sur 60 milliards par
rapport à à l'intérêt vas-y
aux intérêts de la dette annuelle. Si
non c'est ça.
Fact check. On clique le capitaine fact.
Je pense qu'on est à peu près sur le
budget euh le budget de l'éducation
nationale chaque année. Oui, c'est ça.
Ça doit être 50 60 milliards d'euros.
Euh on va vérifier mais vous me direz.
Euh la question
qui se pose aujourd'hui,
comment on fait pour s'en sortir alors
qu'il y a des prédateurs partout, que on
a des brebis qui se prennent pour des
gros cerveaux, qui ont rien vu venir,
qui s'agitent, qui font du bruit avec
leur bouche, qui font des réunions, la
coalition des volontaires, la croisière
s'amuse et que je vais mettre l'économie
russe à genou et que je fais 1000
milliards en plus en 7 ans. et que on
est des cadors de du har de la licorne
sauvage la licorne sauvage
startnop nation mais qu'en fait derrière
c'est que du vent et que du bruit avec
la bouche. Moi je vois une situation
économique qui est dramatique. Je vois
une Union européenne dirigée par des
Carenes, des crétins, des mecs mégalot
qui ne pent rien à la géopolitique, qui
n'ont rien vu venir et qui viennent pas
nous chercher parce que comme nous on a
des vidéos qui prouvent qu'on avait
anticipé le bordel, ils viennent pas
faire les malins chez nous.
La France, elle fait comment pour se
sortir de leur lière ? Elle se barre de
l'Union européenne, elle claque la
porte, elle transforme l'Allemagne comme
sa petite servante et sbrette en lui
coupant l'électricité, en lui disant
maintenant Gunter, tu continues de faire
le malin, ça va commencer à nous
énerver. Reste à ta place parce que
sinon on va s'énerver. Donc on a moi je
pense que vous êtes sur le bon chemin.
C'est quand on propose pas qu'on n pas
on prépare pas l'élection présidente
mais c'est ce que je dis mais c'est
c'est les propositions qu'on fait sont
dans ce sens-là. C'est la sortie la
proposition de référendum sur sortie de
l'Union européenne et de l'euro. Ça vise
à quoi ? à obtenir une évaluation
compétitive
qu'on est obligé de mettre en œuvre
aujourd'hui. On est obligé aujourd'hui
parce que on est dans une situation, on
est en train de se faire massacrer à
cause de l'équivalent de l'Europarque en
gros et qui nous empêche justement de
développer à l'exportation un certain
nombre de marchés. Vous ajoutez à ça en
effet la question de du prix de
l'énergie, c'est du fait qu'on brade
après cette après avoir massacré le le
système
industriel français. de mettre Gunter à
sa place parce que quand il sera réarmé
comme un gor compliqué. Est-ce que c'est
pas maintenant ? Vous allez me dire, on
a Emmanuel Macron, président de la duara
de la licorne, ça va être compliqué de
le voir un peu grossir ses muscles. Son
ambigué stratégique, soné stratégique
qui est digne d'un roman de série Z
indienne.
C'est ce que je disais sur le fait sa
faiblesse le fait dépendre d'autres
d'autres acteurs faibles. Donc en
l'occurrence Mert Starmer, on pourrait
il s'est éloigné justement de de Sanchez
parce que celui-ci commence à
s'autonomiser par rapport à Morfrit se
se réarmer là. Ben c'est moi qui en ai
parlé de tout à l'heure. Bon ben alors
c'est qu'il y a il y a et surtout qui
commence à avoir des des panzers assez
efficaces euh qu'on alors que nous on
galère à moderniser nos leclairs. On
peut rentrer dans le détail sur
l'armement et sur les insuffisances
qu'on a même même et même les la
contestation que l'on pourrait avoir
face aux choix stratégiques qui ont été
fait sur le nouveau porte-avion
gigantesque
au lieu d'avoir deux portesavion qui
nous permettrai d'avoir une permanence
en mer et du coup en fait de faire face
notamment avec en fait aujourd'hui il
faut que ce soit des portes drones
principalement évidemment qu'il faut
qu'on continue à voir il faut qu'on
sorte aussi du projet Scaf. Il faut
c'est quoi cette idée de de s'enfermer
avec l'Allemagne dans un partenariat
dont on sait très bien qu'ils ne veulent
pas et qui leur permettent de de nous
ralentir sur le développement du
prochain rafale et on peut on peut
rentrer sur toutes ces questions. On
peut mais avant ça comme vous le dites,
il y a la question de l'électricité de
l'énergie de façon générale. On a
sacrifié une grande partie de notre
écosystème industriel et économique en
acceptant cette ce fonctionnement du
marché européen de l'énergie et en
fixant sur le gaz le le le le prix le
prix de l'électricité. La question qui
se pose une fois qu'on va sortir de ce
mécanisme, c'est point de départ, mais
c'est aussi il va falloir commencer à
vendre non plus à prix inférieur au prix
coûtant parce qu'aujourd'hui on vend en
gros à 66 € le MAW au lieu de alors
qu'on alors que DF ça lui coûte
peut-être un/ers de plus de façon
générale. Il va falloir à un moment
donné qu'on fasse payer la permanence de
notre production électrique aux autres
pays de l'Union européenne.
qui eux ont fait le choix qui est de
l'UR que qu'on peut comprendre du de
l'énergie le sujet de l'énergie.
J'entends par exemple, on les salue
d'ailleurs le PR Françoise Linot et et
ses électeurs.
La France quand elle, admettons dans le
compte de Ououi, on arrive à dire frit,
on vous emmerde, barrez-vous, on vous
laisse avec Karen et Pécor 1, pécor 2.
Va y avoir des mesures de rétorsion.
Ils vont essayer de nous faire des
croques en jambes. Ils vont essayer de
les marchés vont nous attaquer. C'est
ça.
Mais c'est pour ça que c'est pour ça que
je dis qu'on est obligé on on est obligé
de mettre un contrôle contrôle
d'échange. on est obligé de d'assumer
une dévaluation qui va être dure parce
que quand on envisage la dernière fois
qu'on a envisagé sérieusement une sortie
de l'euro, c'était au moment de la crise
des dettes, la surcrise 2008
2013-23,
c'est-à-dire la deuxème crise, il y a la
crise des subprimes et il y a l'Union
européenne qui à un moment donné recrée
la Banque centrale européenne avec
Trichet crée une surprise du fait d'une
forme de rigorisme complètement déplacé
sur les politiques monétaires
qui nous qui nous mettent qui nous
mettent en en difficulté qui vont
regénérer la crise qu'on est en train de
payer aujourd'hui. À ce moment-là, la
base industrielle de la France à peu
près 17 % du PIB. Aujourd'hui, on est à
10 11. Voyez ? Donc, en fait, là où il
fallait faire une évaluation compétitive
de 20 30 % il y a 10 ans, aujourd'hui il
faut que ce soit 30 40 %. Or, c'est pas
du tout les mêmes conséquences pour le
consommateur français. C'est en terme de
perte de capacité acquisitive de
produits étrangers et ça, il va falloir
le faire accepter à la population. le
fait qu'il y a un certain nombre de
biens qui vont coûter plus cher et qui
va falloir en échange.
Est-ce que les Français sont prêts
sacrifice ?
C'est la grande question. Est-ce qu'on
on a cet endormissement dont on parlait
sur la politique par rapport aux
stupéfiants, en fait, elle s'applique
aussi en politique économique de façon
générale. On a créé un peuple de
consommateurs zombies et c'est pour ça
que je suis si dur avec la gauche Zara
avec le NFP mais aussi avec la France
insoumise qui défend euh Urby Orby cette
cette position depuis qu'ils ont renoncé
justement à tout plan de sortie de
l'Union européenne et de l'euro. Ce qui
pour moi une trahison fondamentale parce
que on se retrouve à une situation où en
gros on fait le paris. C'est
en fait on on n pas de différence
fondamentale avec la Macronie actuelle
économiquement parlant si ce n'est sur
la politique d'agentification de l'État.
C'est que c'est vrai qu'il y a une prise
en considération par la gauche de la
nécessité d'avoir des services publics
qui soient plus importantes que celle
qui existe aujourd'hui. Mais s'il y a
pas un réajustement général, on va pas
rajouter des dépenses à celles qui
existent déjà. On se retrouve dans une
situation qui amène à l'effondrement
économique et qui est intuitivement euh
ressenti par une partie de la population
qui du coup génère une forme de rejet à
l'égard de ses forces politiques et qui
ne les amène pas à devenir euh dominante
comme comme elle comme comme elle
pourrait l'être. Et donc nous, on prend
le pari qu'à un moment donné la
réindustrialisation de la France va
devoir passer par une un protectionnisme
économique avec des droits de douane en
fait similaire à la politique qui été
adoptée par Trump sur un certain nombre
de secteurs pour préserver
le différentiel écologique et social
qu'il y a en France par rapport à ces à
ces espaces. On a des atouts, on a des
atouts là-dedans, notamment le prix de
l'électricité, notre parc nucléaire.
rentrer dans le détail euh en façon
comment vous allez gérer ça. Admettons,
par le plus grand des hasards, je prends
ma baguette magique,
Branco, président. Euh votre premier
ministre, ce sera qui ?
Bah, je vais pas vous le dire
maintenant, mais on a des idées assez
assez précises, bien sûr, mais on va pas
vous le dire maintenant. Mais
en dessous de 50 ans plus de 50 ans ?
Non, plus de 50 ans.
D'accord. Bon, le premier ministre plus
de 50 ans, il y a encore des herzats de
force.
politique de réseau de prise de contrôle
de réseau institutionnel.
Ou c'est pour ça qu'on est très content
d'avoir les îles gargales. C'est qu'en
fait il va falloir il va falloir il va
falloir avoir une verticale. Ah il va il
va il va falloir
non il non ça pas saigné. Nous nous on
veut pas du d'atteinte au corps. Par
contre il va falloir à un moment donné
faire autorité sur un certain nombre de
personnes qui ont vécu sur le dos de la
bête depuis des décennies qui nous ont
mené dans le mur actuel. Donc ça euh la
politique de la France se fait pas la
Corbeille, disait De Gaulle. Donc on est
vraiment sur cette disposition-là qui
consiste à soumettre les forces qui
chercheront à trahir la nation et elles
vont être elles vont être soumises à la
fois par une comme il faut il faut voir
le dispositif d'ensemble. C'est-à-dire
que dès qu'on rentre dans le pouvoir
donc à 6 mois il y a les référendums sur
l'euro et l'Union européenne mais il y a
tout de suite la libération des médias.
C'est qu'il faut tout de suite se
débarrasser du système oligarchique
actuel qui fait que la pensée des
Français est sinon déterminée, du moins
influencée par des personnes qui
achètent des journalistes pour les
amener dans cette directionlà. Or ça
sert à rien d'organiser des référendums
si on vous dit quoi penser et si on n'
pas une des personnes qui honnêtement
vont essayer de générer un débat qui va
vous amener à vous faire votre propre
idée et seulement essayer de vous
distraire ou ou de vous
instrumentaliser. Donc il va falloir
soumettre ces forces là qui il se
trouvent se font de l'argent sur le dos
de la bête parce que les oligarques ils
font pas ça par Uris et par désir du
pouvoir. Ils font ça parce que ça leur
permet d'accéder à des marchés d'état.
la téléphonie notamment par exemple la
téléphonie c'est des milliards d'euros
qui chaque année sont pris euh aux
français à travers une sorte de cartel
qui a été organisé entre BUIG et SFR euh
Free et Orange où qui a fait la fortune
de gens comme Xavier Niel, comme Martin
Big et comme d'autres. Donc ça on on
s'en libère, on s'en débarrasse et on va
faire ça secteur par secteur.
Non mais vous mais vous croyez pas un
peu trop au Père Noël ?
Non, on croit à l'autorité, à la force
du peuple qui impose sa volonté. Ça me
croit la possibilité de faire un coup
d'état.
On n'est pas foutu de calmer quatre
nanas en mobylette des rodéo. Bah nous
le peuple donc nous l'état.
C'est pas la même chose.
Quand quand vous prenez le métro que il
y a des embrouilles, je vois pas les
gens lever le menton. Vous vous avez
déjà vu une embrouille dans le métro de
Moscou ?
Ça se termine mal pour celui qui
embrouille. [rires]
Euh en France, il y a des embrouilles
dans le métro, des gamines qui sont
violés au fond des wagons, personne ne
bouge. Bon, nous on doit être un peu
trop cutéreux et campagnard ou
montagnard
ou complètement cinglé. Mais non, on
l'attrape et on le traîne. Puis on le
traîne de façon compliquée.
Ouais. Bah, ça serait peut-être bien
d'éviter d'avoir en arrivé là, non ? De
préférence, c'estàd qu'on arrive à voir
un état qui réussisse à
neutralise en lui brisant chaque
articulation. Oui, c'est légitime
défense ou pas ?
On peut essayer de faire on peut essayer
de faire mieux et plus civilisé mais
plus efficace aussi. Et c'est pas avec
les prisons actuelles,
mais c'est pas avec le système
judiciaire et avec les prisons actuelles
qu'on y arrivera. Et donc l'élection des
juges,
l'élection des juges qui permet au
peuple français à un moment donné
d'avoir une justice qui soit celle qu'il
désire.
D'accord. Mais pour envoyer Pierre Paul
Jacques qui se gave depuis des années
aux île Cargelen
Ouais.
Il va vous objecter le droit, il va vous
objecter
va il va object
et alors
bah il sera au Cargalen.
Mais vous allez l'envoyer comment ? Avec
comme les TFC ? Non, je sais pas. On a
des A400M. Non, c'est pas mal comme avec
ou sans parachute ?
Non non, avec parachute avec des
mouettes. Enfin, il y a un toit qui va
qui va exposer tranquillement. Ah non
mais non non mais on va on va s'assurer
qu' parce que moi j'ai envie qu'il y
passe un peu de temps au cargalen c'est
très joli, c'est un territoire français,
il faut qu'il le développe puisque c'est
des gens si talentueux, des grands
entrepreneurs tels qu'ils nous sont
décrits par par entière. Je suis sûr
qu'ils vont mais je suis sûr qu'ils vont
réussir à en faire des des points de
rayonnement de la France. C'est prê
c'est près de l'Antarctique pour ceux
qui savent pas où sont les cargen. On
sait que les forces de l'ordre vont vous
aider à les à vous saisir mais
les forces de l'ordre elles vont obéir.
Il y a un moment donné si on arrive avec
la volonté populaire. Voyez, si on
continue dans une situation où les
colères, c'est je pense le titre de
votre émission. Euh,
j'ai vu j'ai vu j'ai vu la la il faut
vraiment rendre hommage à la
coordination rurale. C'est dommage qu'on
l' pas fait en en début de en début
d'émission. Je le regrette parce que
c'est c'est un syndicat qui s'est
construit euh face à une situation
monopolistique pour le coup de la FNSE
qui est celle qui nous a amené en
coopération avec les autorités de l'État
dans le mur de l'agriculture de
l'agroindustrie intensive et
productiviste qui en effet euh au sortir
de la guerre nous a permis de sortir de
la dépendance à l'égard euh des marchés
agricoles étrangers, des pénuries que ça
pouvait produire, mais qui a très
rapidement épuisé le sol et qui nous met
aujourd'hui dans une situation
où on est prêt à déstabiliser d'autant
plus c'est que les choix géopolitiques
qui sont faits et notamment le blé
ukrainien et on peut en parler de façon
détaillé mais qu'importe on a un moment
la CR qui arrive en fait à rompre avec
cette situation et qui arrive à produire
des actions et saisir les autorités face
à des des décisions comme celles qui
consistent à nous faire adhérer au
Mercosur c'est très intéressant le
Mercosur parce que je là on les voit
sortir hein les les turifires du pouvoir
les petits courtisans qui commencent à
défendre cet accord et ils disent oui
mais regardez
C'est que 200000 tonnes de bœuf. Alors
et des gens intelligents, leur object,
oui, mais c'est les par les plus nobles.
Donc enfin en réalité, c'est ce qui
permet aux agriculteurs de faire le mal,
aux éleveurs de refaire leur marge. Et
tout le reste dépend en fait de cette
capacité à agir sur les sur les parties
nobles de du de la bête. Mais il faut
aller au-delà. Mais regardez en échange,
on va pouvoir leur vendre des services,
des voitures. Et donc en fait, on est en
train de faire exactement ce qu'on a
fait avec la Chine. C'est on se dit
"Oui, mais en fait, on va tout leur
déverser et ça va rester comme ça." et
et on voit pas qu'en fait la baisse de
nos barrières protectrices va un moment
donné pour commencer mais que très
rapidement va y avoir une montée en
gamme et des transferts de compétences
et ainsi de suite avec ces pays du de
l'Amérique latine qui à un moment donné
vont nous prendre des marchés. Il faut
arrêter de prendre on on n'est pas nos
avantages compétitifs, nos puissances
industrielles, elles sont le fruit d'une
époque où nous avions un accès aux
matières premières et notalement aux
ressources énergétiques qui nous ont
permis d'être les premiers à être
industrialisés. On n'est pas des génies
par la grâce de Dieu. On a on avait un
capital sur lequel on a pu prospérer qui
nous a amené à faire n'importe quoi que
ce soit la colonisation, les guerres
mondiales et tout ça mais qui a quand
même laissé un appareil productif majeur
qu'on est et on est en bout de course,
on est en train de finir de profiter de
cet avantage et malheureusement on n'a
pas su se convertir à temps et sur
toutes les nouvelles technologies on est
complètement largué parce que à un
moment donné il y a pas eu cette
conversion qui est intervenue et cette
conversion n'est pas intervenue
notamment parce qu'on s'est ouvert
mais au cas de vent que ce soit à la
Chine Chine ou à d'autres qui eux ont
fait une remontée de filière
progressivement et qui ont commencé à
grapiller nos savoirs. On se fichit de
leur de leur gueule il y a il y a 20
ans, j'en parle même pas mais même il y
a 10 ans encore. Moi je me souviens il y
a 10 ans des discours sur les Chinois
qui savent que copier qui c'était
c'était encore dominant et aujourd'hui
c'est eux qui sont en innovation qui
font dipsiqu là nous on est avec on est
largué comme avec Mistral sur sur le sur
l'IA mais surtout c'est eux qui
fabriquent voyez par exemple avec avec
les c'est très important les processeurs
les microprocesseurs et les transistors
c'est la capacité aggravée en dessous de
tr on est à 3 nanom on est à deux
maintenant euh bon on pourrait revenir
les les gens les plus subtils savent que
c'est pas c'est c'est que des valeurs
indicatives que c'est pas les vraies
valeurs de Gravion, mais qu'importe
euh quand les États-Unis et Taiwan ont
tenter de priver la Chine de l'accès
d'une part au aux cartes graphiques
Nvidia mais aussi à ces technologies de
gravure particulière, ils ont réussi en
quelques années à atteindre ce niveau de
gravure. Pourquoi c'est très très
important ? parce que plus c'est fin,
plus on arrive à mettre de transistors
sur la même surface et donc plus notre
appareil est puissant, que ce soit le
téléphone, l'ordinateur ou ou tout autre
type d'appareil industriel. Et donc
nous, on a avec
nous on a la technologie en Europe, la
dernière grande technologie qui nous qui
nous reste dans ce domaine, c'est celui
qui permet en gros de fabriquer les
machines qui fabriquent les euh les les
puces
qui est au Pays-Bas. Donc héritier de
Philippe, j'en parlais tout à l'heure.
En quelques années, ils sont arrivés,
ils sont en train d'arriver là avec
Huawei notamment du fait de des
sanctions qu'ils ont fait l'objet, ils
sont en train d'arriver au même degré de
finesse de gravure vraiment à une
vitesse qui était complètement
inattendue pour nous. Nous, on est sauf
erreur de ma part, dans le meilleur des
cas en France, on est à 12 mm. Ce qui ce
qui est vraiment nanomètre, ce qui est
vraiment pas mal du tout. ce qui est
vraiment pas mal du tout et qui en fait
nous permet sur toute une série
d'appareils, réfrigérateurs et compagnie
d'avoir une autonomie stratégique, toute
une série de missiles, toute il y a pas
mal de trucs qu'on peut fabriquer en
propre, mais il y a un écart énorme,
c'est-à-dire qu'on est là où ils étaient
dans le meilleur des cas en 2010 voire
un peu avant. Donc on a ce retard de 15
ans. Soit on essaie
de rattraper ça et on crée on on
investit massivement tout cet argent
qu'on a dilapidé pendant le Covid. Ces
sommes, ces masses qu'on est en capacité
de mobiliser, on les mobilise par
exemple pour mener à bien un tout un
plan de robotisation de l'industrie
fondamentale en France. C'estàd voyez un
nouveau parce que c'est le grand champ
sur lequel à mon avis il y a un
rattrapage qui peut être mise en œuvre
avec une mobilisation. Nouveau nos
écoles d'ingénieurs, les
polytechniciens, il faut qu'ils arrêtent
de partir dans la finance. Voyez, c'est
c'est aussi bête que ça. C'est la
recherche fondamentale qu' dans la
finance. Pourquoi ? Pour pas par
patriotisme ou
non mais parce qu'il y a pas de il y a
pas d'offre d'emploi aussi. C'est qu'il
y a aussi il y a aussi une question très
simple, c'est qu'on a dépriorisé ces
secteursl qu' y a pas d'investissement
suffisant pour accueillir les 400
polytechniciens qui a qui sortent chaque
année de de l'école dans dans des
industries fondamentales en France.
enfin qui fondent de et donc mais
le niveau s'effondre he dans cette dans
ces écoles surtout moi je l'ai vu parce
que moi c'est plus c'est plus mon
domaine mais en lettre anormal supra
vraiment pourquoi parce que c'est des
effets d'accumulation de médiocrité où
euh on abaisse le niveau de recrutement
le mec qui se fait recruter finit par
devenir prof 15 ans plus tard fait les
sujets pour celui qui vient ça devient
de l'endogamie à tous les niveaux grâce
au aux réformes universitaires sur sur
enfin de l'autonomie et tout ça et il y
a et bon bref Donc ça aussi
l'investissement dans la recherche
fondamentale. Moi qui vient de la
recherche qui fait un doctorat qui j'ai
parfaitement conscience
déshabiller Paul pour réhabiller
Jacques. Ça va être qui Paul que vous
allez déshabiller ?
C'est la dévaluation compétitive. C'est
le consommateur.
Combien de pourcent ?
Moi je pense que aujourd'hui ça va être
très difficile en dessous de 30 35 hein.
C'estàd que c'est c'est violent. C'est
violent. Il faut s'y attendre.
La la il y a quoi ? Il y a 50 de têtes.
Je demande à me faire fa checker au
réalisateur. Et le pourcentage de la
population française qui gagne autour de
1800 balles par mois, c'est quoi ? C'est
50 60 %.
Oui, parce qu'en fait la le le revenu
moyen est à 2200.
Euh donc oui, ça doit être ça doit être
ça.
Les personnes qui ne travaillent pas,
qui vivent uniquement de subside, c'est
combien de pourcent ? Il y a combien de
pourcent de la population française
active qui paye l'impôt sur le revenu ?
C'est quoi ? C'est 30 % du pays qui fait
vivre le
Non, attention parce que l'impôt sur
revenu n'est pas du tout la masse la
plus importante en terme de de rentrée
fiscale. Ça c'est important quand même
de le savoir. On paye tous la TVA et
compagnie. Si on se tape une dévaluation
compétitive, ce que qui est d'ailleurs
mal formulé je pense dans le terme,
ça va s'énerver quand même un peu.
Bah ça dépend si on s' le sevrage
énergétique parce que c'est un sevrage
énergétique et calorifique.
Non, je suis pas d'accord. Je pense
qu'on a une capacité à maintenir notre
capacité de pardon
moins 35 % de gens qui sont déjà ras à
chasser la promotion à chasser
non parce que parce que vous avez vous
avez des leviers importants par exemple
sur la TVA sur les produits de première
nécessité comme l'a fait l'Espagne vous
avez des leviers de compensatoires qui
permettent d'éviter que sur justement la
population la plus précarisée
aujourd'hui et la plus en difficulté qui
a pas d'impact sur eux sinon sinon
évidemment c'est un massacre social et
ça vaut pas la peine. Faut pas il y a et
il y a aussi une captation des euh du
patrimoine. Aujourd'hui, une grande
partie de notre richesse artificielle,
elle est liée à la la survalorisation de
l'immobilier qui en réalité il y a pas
de raison que ce qui valait il y a 10
ans, 10 fois moins qu'aujourd'hui ait eu
cette explosion. Réduction du stock, il
y a pas beaucoup de bien.
Non, c'est pas ce qui se passe en
France. En à Paris, par exemple, il y a
une baisse du nombre d'habitants. Donc
c'est pas du tout lié à une une tension
sur sur la demande. C'est on est on est
en train on va bientôt passer sous les 2
millions d'habitants en France. Il y a
une perte vraiment de euh de à Paris,
pardon. Donc on est on est sur une
situation où où en réalité c'est juste
lié aux dynamiques spéculative lié à
notre appartenance à l'euro et de façon
plus générale à notre absence de
barrière par rapport aux investissements
étrangers qui partent dans dans des
biens sur lesquels ils ne ils n'ont même
pas l'usufruist. Enfin, ils ne les
utilisent pas. C'est bien. Les quartiers
entiers de Paris sont vides, mais
appartiennent à des grands fonds qui qui
mettent leur argent dedans dans
l'hypothèse que un jour ils pourront le
revendre avec un facteur multipli
multipliant de deux tr fois. Donc la
recherche fondamentale
c'est l'université, les chercheurs, le
fait qu'aujourd'hui, le fait que il faut
si à un moment donné vous repartez pas
de cette base, si vous vous retrouvez
avec une situation où il vaut mieux être
caissier que d'être prof dans le
secondaire. et que le prof du secondaire
arrive pas à faire autorité parce qu'il
a à peine le salaire d'un caissier avec
un peu d'expérience. Évidemment, les
gamins vont pas le regarder comme une
figure de référence. Vous vous générez
des effets comme ça de désaffiliation et
le trafic de stupéfiant, c'est pas pour
faire la morale sur la drogue, c'est un
les effets déstructurant sur la société.
D'accord. Ça c'est une chose, mais c'est
aussi l'effet signal quand vous quand
vous avez la facilité avec laquelle vous
pouvez gagner de l'argent euh en étant
juste à partir du à même les guetteteurs
même les gueteurs évidemment toute toute
cette construction hiérarchique sociale
elle manque elle envoie un effet signal
catastrophique à un moment donné si vous
faites de l'effort au quotidien parce
que vous croyez en ce que vous faites
parce que vous êtes infirmier parce que
et que à côté vous voyez qu'il y a une
partie toujours grandissante de la
société qui en a rien rien à faire qui
en a rien à faire du bien commun qui est
dans un rapport de sauf qui sauf qui
peut bah évidemment vous avez un
effondrement de l'ensemble ce prisme de
lecture sur la génération
only fan
mais ça fait partie mais je pense qu'on
en avait parlé dans dans un de un de nos
interview précédents
la violence aujourd'hui d'être une femme
d'une jeune femme en France et et à quel
point c'est c'est perturbant et un jeune
homme d'ailleurs aussi en réalité parce
que à quel point tout d'un coup euh
l'impression euh que le succès peut et
potentiellement doit reposer sur
l'esthétique, sur l'apparence euh et à
quel point le succès devient aussi une
valeur en soi. Vous voyez ? Et le succès
incarné comment ? Par la capacité à se
payer des bouteilles de champagne avec
des bougies au-dessus qui enflamment
l'endroit où vous est passé votre 31
décembre. C'est euh que vous allez
filmer plutôt que de prendre la poudre
d'escampettes euh parce que vous avez
pas de réflexe de Non, c'est important.
C'est
sont fait prendre par les fumées. Euh il
pit du plastique sur la ce qui est
important, qu'est-ce que je suis en
train de vous dire ? C'est que on est on
est sur une situation où la euh on avait
une société pour le meilleur et pour le
pire structurée sur un certain nombre de
valeurs euh dans lesquelles étaient
récompensés les comportements qui
amenaient à contribuer d'une façon ou
d'une autre au biencommand. Et c'est
pour ça par exemple que c'est important
euh de se battre contre le discours
d'Emmanuel Macron sur le fait qu'il
prétendrait que tout le monde veut
devenir milliardaire. En fait, la seule
ambition quand on veut devenir
milliardaire, quand on le dit comme ça,
c'est de vouloir s'exfiltrer de la
société et milliardaire celui qui peut
faire ce qu'il veut sans aucune
contrainte. C'est ça le fantasme
derrière. Et il faut promouvoir
l'inverse. Le fantasme ça doit être de
vouloir être médecin, de vouloir être
policier, pompier, on s'en fout. de de
participer au bien commun, de vouloir
être artiste, de de vouloir générer de
la beauté. C'est ça. C'est pas la c'est
pas le moyen de s'en sortir, c'est au
contraire le moyen de rentrer, de
contribuer, d'avoir une fonction. C'est
notre mouvement, c'est l'objectif de
notre mouvement, c'est quoi ? C'est que
tout le monde retrouve une fonction au
sein de la société. Si on a une un
regard comme votre prise de lecture peut
y amener, c'estàd où à force de tout
regarder à travers le prisme énergétique
de la de la de la ressource en tant que
telle, on finit par perdre de vue que ce
qui compte c'est qu'une société tienne.
Et pour qu'une société tienne, il faut
qu'il y ait des interdépendances entre
chacun.
Vous connaissez le proverbe ?
Quand il n'y a plus de foin dans les
rateliers, les chevaux se battent. Oui.
Est-ce que vous pensez pas que vous êtes
un petit peu bisouour sur le fait que
tout le monde doit avoir son rôle dans
la société,
que tout le monde il est beau, il est
gentil. Est-ce que vous regardez pas un
peu passer en face les sociopathes, les
groupes de pression de sociopathes, les
concentrations de sociopathes, les gens
qui se qui restent entre eux dans les
dans certaines administrations pour se
tenir, pour s'épauler, pour se protéger.
Mais
je pense que c'est l'inverse.
Est-ce que eux est-ce que eux vous allez
leur trouver du boulot ? Et je pense que
c'est l'inverse. Eux réussissent à
constituer des réseaux de solidarité en
profitant de l'absence d'autorité et de
l'absence d'enliaisement proposé par et
l'État et la société dans son ensemble.
C'est qu'il constituent des
microsociétés qui contournent de façon
plus large nation française et ce qu'on
pourrait leur apporter. Ces réseaux de
solidarité à parar que ce soit enfin bon
bref on les connaît tous. Ils ont pour
vocation à à à combler des manques soit
d'autorité, soit au contraire d'offres
qui euh qui sont faites. Par exemple, la
mo moi j'ai beaucoup de clients et en
province c'est très marquant qui me
parlent très souvent de l'influence de
la franc-maçonnerie de la justice.
Voyez, une sorte d'en disant "Mais j'en
peux plus, telle décision, telle autre
décision, c'est les loges, je sais pas
quoi." Euh il y a il y a pas il y a rien
de plus défaillant que la justice en
France. Il y a rien de plus insuffisant
aujourd'hui. Vous passez des années pour
n'importe quel contentieux sans avoir de
réponse. Ça paralyse votre vie. Que sou
c'est victime ou mise en cause, que ce
soit de façon juste ou injuste. Tout ça
pour finir avec des décisions qui sont
difficiles à faire exécuter quand elles
quand vous quand elles sont exécutables
tout simplement. Quand il s'agit de
peine de prison pour sanctionner des
comportements déviants, il faut qu'elle
soit exécuté exécutoire, ce qui est
souvent pas le cas. Il faut que la peine
de prison soit réelle, pas une peine de
prison avec surcis ou aménageable ou
avec bracelet ou je ne sais quoi. Il
faut que quand vous êtes en prison, la
personne qui est en prison soit
véritablement isolé du reste de la
société, qu'elle est vraiment qu'elle se
retrouve pas à qu à qu dans un dans une
cellule de 10 m² avec du chit partout.
Et vous voyez et tout ça aujourd'hui ne
fonctionne plus du tout, ne n'est plus
du tout effectif. Et donc on en ressort
à des moyens de règlement alternatif des
conflits en quelque sorte. on en ressort
a des effets y compris de corruption qui
se développent pour essayer de survivre
dans et donc on a une individualisation
qui gangraine la société. Donc refaire
autorité, reproposer une refonte de
l'ensemble de de ces dispositifs,
l'élection des juges par exemple, c'est
fondamental. On a aujourd'hui les juges,
c'est quoi ? C'est des gamins qui a 23
ans on réussi un concours, donc qui ont
eu le privilège entre 18 et 23 ans un de
faire des études supérieures, d'avoir le
temps à consacré, à préparer un concours
dont il n'était pas sûr de l'obtenir.
Donc je peux vous dire que déjà en terme
de filtre social, on sait qu' qu'il peut
se permettre de passer un an ou deux à
préparer un concours sans aucune source
de rémunération alternative et qui passe
2 ans dans une école plutôt plutôt avec
un cursus plutôt bien fait. Il tournent
et puis après toute leur vie, ils vont
décider de la vie de gens. sans jamais
avoir à supporter une quelconque
conséquence s'ils font n'importe quoi,
si vous voyez ça c'est pas possible le
le vous avez plus près de 15000 césignes
qui ont été faites par des citoyens
contre des juges dans une un mécanisme
qui a été proposé il y a quelques
années. Vous avez 01 % de décisions qui
favorables qui ont été retenues. Vous
avez trois blames qui ont été octroyées.
mesure en terme de guerre économique
avec la géopolitique qu'on est qu'on
subit
remonté de filière notamment dans
l'industrie notamment avec la
robotisation il faut faire de la
remontée de filière faut faire de
l'espionnage économique de façon massive
il faut récupérer un certain nombre de
talents qu'on a perdus il faut durcir de
façon majeur c'est ce que je disais sur
la contrainte par rapport aux grandes
écoles d'ingénieur fait faut récupérer
les meilleurs, faut le faut leur
adjoindre un service obligatoire au sein
de l'État normal avant normal et
polytechnique vous étiez obligé de
donner 10 ans à l'État. Aujourd'hui, de
facto, c'est c'est beaucoup moins
appliqué voire pas du tout appliqué. Et
ça n'est pas en grande partie parce que
on avait pas de déboucher à leur offrir.
On savait pas quoi en faire de ces
gamins. Il faut il faut recommencer à
bien payer les chercheurs. Vous avez un
au CNRS, vous y rentrez à un back bac +
8. Après, ben vous rentrez à moins de
2000 € par mois. Enfin, vous rendez
compte ou pas ? On est dans des
situations qui sont aberes.
Une mission d'autorité beaucoup plus
importante par rapport au réseaux de
corruption de de trafic de stupéfiant et
autres. Une refonte complète notamment
des services de renseignement pour
qu'ils arrêtent de chasser les opposants
et qui commencent enfin à s'engager sur
la défense des intérêts véritables de la
nation. Une refonte de la des alliances
géopolitiques avec un un accès à nouveau
aux ressources dont on a été privé
notamment en Russie. Il faut arrêter de
faire les per la morale si on est
incapable par ailleurs de tenir notre
position euh sur les conflits dans
lesquels on on prétend s'engager. Et peu
à peu comme ça vous redessinez en fait
une cartographie de la France qui la
remet sur 10 à 15 ans en position de
redevenir la puissance industrielle
qu'elle qu'elle n'aurait jamais dû
cesser d'être et la deuxè puissance
économique mondiale qui était 60.
Et à un moment donné, vous voyez bien
comment en quelques années, le général
de Gaulle a réussi à retendre tout
l'appareil d'État pour le mettre dans
une direction qui nous a permis de
produire des prouesses économiques et
industrielles. Et à un moment donné, il
faut il faut faire cet effort et cet
effort requiert une certaine autorité.
On est on est sur
600 propositions là sur la 8e version du
projet qu'on a qu'on a élaboré sur sur
les ruches que je vous incite à
consulter. Sur chacun des domaines, on
essaie de traiter en profondeur
l'agriculture. L'agriculture, c'est très
compliqué de sortir de l'Union
européenne. Euh c'estàd que on sort d'un
mécanisme, la PAC, qui a hypers
subventionné une forme agricole, qui
nous a permis d'atteindre une autonomie
et une souveraineté agricole. Il faut
pas détruire cet appareil industriel. Il
faut dans cette sortie-là qui est
devenue nécessaire articuler les
politiques agricoles pour s'assurer que
euh on on puisse maintenir cette
capacité exportatrice que l'on a eu
pendant si longtemps. Donc on prend pas
les choses à la légère mais par contre
on a conscience de l'urgence des
procédés.
Je fais passer un message au chat où il
y a les questions euh qui s'amoncellent.
voter entre vous pour que on choisisse
très facilement la question qui a le
plus de pouces vers le haut ou de plus
de likes ou vous avez 5 minutes.
Revenons à nos sujets entre vous et moi.
On arrive bientôt à l'élection
présidentielle. Euh vous vous combien
d'adhérents ? Donc on a créé ce
mouvement, on a en 25000 membres, ce qui
est euh euh ce qui est très bien par
rapport à la France parce que
rappelez-vous Renaissance à 8000 membres
aujourd'hui, c'est vraiment pitoyable.
Mais ce qui pose un problème
qu'on par au dernier de la classe,
voilà ce qui [rires] un peu pitoyable à
l'échelle euh c'est que quand j'étais au
Mexique, j'ai j'ai beaucoup échangé avec
les responsables qui sont aujourd'hui au
pouvoir. Le parti Morena a 4 millions de
membres. Donc qu'est-ce que ça dit de la
dépolitisation d'un pays où le parti qui
a le plus d'adhérents et il faut voir ce
qui est vrai ou ce qui est pas vrai,
c'est à peu près 100000 sur une
population de quasiment 70 millions
d'habitants. c'est dire qu'on est dans
une situation où en réalité il y a un
désengagement massif et moi j'ai
beaucoup vu au début sur notre mouvement
il y avait beaucoup ça a été miraculeux
en terme de de proposition d'action et
d'engagement mais aussi beaucoup de gens
qui venaient avec un comportement de
consommateur c'est qui s'attendaiit à ce
qu'on soit des prestataires de service
et qui ont pas compris qu'en fait ce
pays il va falloir le reconstruire et
que pour le construire il faut qu'on
construise nous-même notre mouvement
d'abord c'est qu'on on n'est pas là pour
quémander on n'est pas là pour demander
est-ce que notre projet est un projet
d'engagement
vraiment de de lutte pour une
souveraineté. La souveraineté, c'est
facile de de l'agiter. Mais faut faut
avoir à l'esprit ce que ça ça me fait
penser au Vénézuela, on a beaucoup parlé
sur sur Hugo Chavez et les conséquences
que ces politiques économiques ont eu ou
pas. Le grand la grande difficulté à
laquelle a été confronté Hugo Chavez
quand il cherche cette révolution,
c'était les les fils de Bourgeois.
C'était toute cette élite Comprador qui
en fait s'était habitué depuis 30 ans
grâce à au pétrole à ne pas bosser.
Et et en fait, il était il est arrivé au
pouvoir dans un pays qui ne produisait
plus, qui s'était installé dans une
forme de confort qui est quand même
similaire à celui qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui en France. Et la question
maintenant qui se pose, c'est comment
est-ce qu'on remet cette partie de la
population qui n'est plus active au sens
profond du terme à travailler à nouveau
et on lui dit maintenant bah il faut
offrir des horizons. Il faut en fait que
c'est un sens d'aller dans cette
direction là. Et ce sens-là, il peut pas
exister quand on on voit le niveau
d'égalité, de violence sociale qui
existe dans ce pays euh avec euh surtout
de prédation des ressources communes.
C'est pas tant. Je suis pas sûr que la
gauche ait raison euh quand elle pense
que c'est vrai qu'on est un pays qui
socialement cherche à lutter contre les
égalités. La question qui se pose, c'est
la prédation de la ressource commune.
C'est le fait qu'il y ait pas de service
public de base qui soit offert aux
citoyens français, qu'il y ait pas de
médecin qui soit accessible dans une
grande partie du territoire. Vous voyez,
c'est des c'est des choses aussi simples
que celle-ci. Si vous n'offrez plus ça,
ça sert à rien de filer des minimas
sociaux, de filer enfin la la base de
toute lien social, il doit être sur
l'offre commune en terme de service de
base, vous voyez, de service euh d'État.
Moi, je suis pas du tout sur une
politique de la subvention à à Toubout
de champ. Or, malheureusement,
aujourd'hui, c'est ce qui est proposé
par
le budget, il fait combien d'économie ?
Je pense qu'on est sur une réduction de
de euh alors c'est compliqué parce que
en fait c'est s
si c'est compliqué parce que c'est parce
que justement la dévaluation euh fait
que les les ordres de grandeur sont
faussés. C'est 100 milliards par rapport
à la base actuelle. En réalité, il y a
une partie qui est dissipée par euh par
les dévaluations qu'on qu'on met en
œuvre.
Si je vous dis il faut faire 250
milliards d'économie, vous êtes capable
de faire un budget
100 milliards. 100 milliards 100
milliards, on on l'a fait. euh 250
milliards, je pense que c'est pas
nécessaire parce que l'investissement
productif permet de faire redémarrer la
la politique économique et surtout en
fait, on a une reconfiguration des
grands des grandes blocs. Ça 250
milliards, c'est éventuellement
nécessaire et encore à ça sera discuté à
système constant, c'est dans l'euro au
sein de du système européenne dans ce
système de libre marché avec les mêmes
dépendances à l'égard et avec une base
productive qui est toujours aussi
faible.
Considérer faire des alliances avec
d'autres partis.
Non, moi je crois moi je crois vraiment
au au fait au à l'importance de la du
pluralisme. Il faut qu'en fait on faire
des alliances pour pouvoir prendre la
présidence.
Oui, mais ça ça
je vais vous parler cash.
Peut-être que vous êtes faiseur de roi.
H
mais si vous voulez prendre la tête de
l'État, ils vont vous marcher dessus.
On va voir.
Non mais on va pas voir.
Si si on va voir.
Les alliances, il va bien falloir faire
des alliances. Si je vous dis si je vous
propose d'une alliance avec
Françoise Lino, vous prenez ou prenez
pas ?
Mais
vous prenez, vous prenez pas, il y a pas
de ma.
Non, je moi je veux pas d'alliance.
D'accord. Je veux pas alliance du tout.
Non, c'est quoi l'enjeu ? L'enjeu c'est
l'enjeu c'est éviter de se faire passer
et se faire marcher dessus.
Non, l'enjeu c'est le coup d'état.
D'accord ? C'est quelles sont les
modalités du coup d'état ? Nous, on est
parti d'une base révolutionnaire, on est
parti des gilets jaunes. La question
c'était comment est-ce qu'on retire le
pouvoir à ceux qui sont en place et
comment est-ce qu'on arrive à à le
redistribuer à la population française.
Donc on a un projet qui a été
collectivement généré à partir de ces
idées-là qui vise à redonner la
souveraineté au peuple français à
l'égard de l'étranger mais aussi au
peuple à l'égard de ses classes
dominantes. La capacité comme en Suisse
à à faire contrepoids ceci. Donc on n
pas besoin de force législative.
L'objectif c'est pas de dominer
l'Assemblée nationale. L'objectif c'est
d'organiser tout de suite des
référendums avec l'article 11 qui
permettent sur les grands sujets
fondamentaux institutionnel Europe et
ainsi de suite de leur rendre la parole.
Donc l'enjeu c'est quoi ? C'est les 500
parrainages. L'enjeu c'est les 500
parrainages qui nous permettent d'être
dans les 8 à 10 personnes qui seront
candidats en 2027. Et à partir de là,
j'ai envie de vous dire ça va aller très
vite parce qu'en fait la distinction va
se faire très rapidement entre ceux qui
sont en capacité de gouverner un État
qui ont une vision pour la France et
ceux qui ne le sont pas. Et dans les
débats, nous verrons très rapidement
ceux qui tiennent la route et ceux qui
ne la tiennent pas. Et donc à ce
moment-là, ça va s'agglomérer
naturellement. Il n'y aura pas besoin de
faire des accords de parties, de
négociation, de d'illusion. Par exemple,
vous parlez de de Solidino, il n'a pas
du tout toute la dimension de
démocratisation et de souveraineté
populaire que l'on propose dans notre
programme. Pour vous donner un exemple,
vous voyez, il y a pas de raison de
renoncer à cette force là au profit d'un
quelconque une quelconque négociation
d'appareil.
Question d'internet. Monsieur Branco,
vous mobilisez le peuple contre les
élites avec un discours populiste
assumé.
Mais l'histoire montre que le populisme
accouche presque toujours d'une nouvelle
élite souvent pire que l'ancienne.
Chavez et sa bolurgesla
en sont la preuve pour rester dans
l'actualité. Votre révolution
échappera-t-elle à ce piège trois points
de suspension ou préparez-vous malgré
vous les futurs oligarques de demain ?
Non, moi je pense qu'il faut il y a il y
a deux il y a deux éléments de réponse.
Le premier, c'est que la politique est
une science humaine et que il y a pas
d'absolu en politique et que il y a des
besoins en instant qui ne sont plus ceux
euh de l'instant d'après. Donc il faut
pas croire qu'on va créer un paradis sur
terre euh qui va durer euh 3
millénaires. L'enjeu, c'est de répondre
à des urgences en terme oligarchique.
La personne qui pose la question
mobilise l'exemple de Chavez. Chavez a
détruit la pauvreté de masse dans son
pays et c'était ça l'urgence qu'il
devait répondre, que son successeur et
régénéré des classes oligarchique euh
c'est le propre justement peut-être
d'insuffisance dans euh la capacité du
peuple à contraindre ses dirigeants. Or
nous ce qu'on propose c'est des
instruments pour que le peuple puisse à
tout moment révoquer ses dirigeants,
puisse à tout moment lui donner un
mandat impératif pour sur un sujet.
Pourquoi le mandat impératif est devenu
important par les gilets jaunes ? parce
que c'était au moment où il voulait
privatiser les aéroports de Paris. Or,
il n'y avait aucune raison d'y procéder
si ce n'était engraisser les banques
d'affaires et les petits amis qui
pourraient devenir actionnaires de cela.
Et donc pour
résorber la dette.
Mais quel Oui, avec les les je sais pas
combien c'était 10 milliards, ils en ont
rajouté 1000 non ? Dans souffer de ma
part. Donc donc on voit bien que
justement ce discours sur la dette était
complètement instrumental, que c'était
pas l'objectif réel qui était poursuivi.
Et donc à un moment donné la possibilité
offerte au peuple de sur un sujet donné
dire ça non, ça j' pas envie de passer
ma vie à gérer tous les problèmes de la
collectivité. On paye pas des
politiciens pour rien. C'est parce qu'en
général dans un monde idéal on n pas
envie d'avoir à s'occuper au quotidien
du problème de trottoir jusqu'à la
question de la défense nationale de
devoir tout articuler en permanence
parce qu'on ferait que ça sinon. Donc,
j'accepte qu'il y ait éventuellement euh
des représentants du peuple, mais à
condition que je puisse les contraindre
sur tous les sujets qui à un moment
donné euh font queon voit bien, qui le
font pas pour l'intérêt général mais
pour leur intérêt particulier.
Question d'internet. Euh, même si on
avait un président qui défendait
l'intérêt commun, que ferait-il face à
Trump ? Moi, je vais amender amender la
question.
Est-ce qu'il faut pas stationner
d'une façon très ostentatoire
juste pour la provoque DM51 à
Saint-Pierre et Micovel ?
Bah moi, j'ai proposé les SNLE au
Groenland donc c'est pas mais moi je
pense que de façon générale qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire face à Trump ? Il faut
faire la même chose par exemple sur les
droits de douane. Il aurait fallu
répliquer sur les droits de douanes.
Et là vous avez une manifestation dans
le beaujelet. Vous avez une
manifestation sur les spiritueux sur les
Non, il y a peut-être une manifestation
à venue montagne mais Alvmh qui va pas
être content de par rapport de de voir
leur marge réduite. C'est ça ce qui va
se passer en réalité.
Pardon, excusez-moi. C'est c'est il faut
qu'on mette du du 3M. Euh
vous avez vu la dernière vidéo de Trump
où il il mimique Emmanuel Macron comme
un gamin de 4 ans qui pleur niche parce
qu'il lui dit si tu continues à faire le
malin d'une façon triviale si tu
continues à faire le malin tes
médicavents c'est 200 %
plus cher chez toi.
Mais pourquoi ? Parce qu'il sait que
c'est une c'est un c'est un vasal. Euh
Emmanuel Macron, ce que je raconte
régulièrement, les de les 200 agents de
la CIA euh à Paris pour cinq agents de
la DGSI chargés de les surveiller, ça
fait partie, il faut regarder le
Venezuela aussi par rapport à ça, par
rapport à une capacité de coup d'état
euh qu'ils ont euh qui à n'importe quel
moment peut être appliqué dans d'autres
territoires et compris en France
et y compris en France pourquoi est-ce
que Bardella et Le Pen sont allés faire
les sous-brettes de à l'ambassade des
États-Unis il y a 3 semaines
auprès
du gendre de de Trump
pas sous BR.
Voilà. Euh c'est pareil pour
c'est encore différent parce que là
c'est une programmation là on est sur la
trahison/ash prostitution pour le RN.
Vous pouvez pas dire ça non plus.
Pourquoi vous dites ça ?
Ah bon ?
que va faire un un un parti prétendument
souverainiste
euh qui a construit tout son discours
depuis 50 ans sur l'indépendance du
pays, qui entre-temps a renoncé à sortir
de l'Union européenne, a renoncé à
sortir de l'euro, euh se retrouve en
position de servilité, de vassalité à
l'égard de l'ambassadeur pour montrer à
quel point ils sont maintenant reconnus
parce qu'ils savent très bien ou ils
pensent savoir qu'ils n'accéderont au
pouvoir que si justement ils ont une
approbation moment de leur part.
Évidemment, moi c'est des ennemis c'est
des ennemis. Hier, ils allaient demander
9 millions d'euros à au Kremelin.
Aujourd'hui, ils viennent le
Rassemblement national le prêt qu'ils
ont eu pour survivre et pour pouvoir se
présenter aux élections, ils le doivent
à la Russie. C'est qui doit pas être
contente aujourd'hui de
Pourquoi en France et je me fais
l'avocat du diable, pourquoi en France
le Front National est obligé d'aller se
financer ailleurs ? Parce que ça coûte
cher de vivre comme vit Marine Le Pen.
Non, parce que peut-être que les banques
lui ont fermé les encrès. Ouis. Et parce
que parce que ça coûte cher de vivre
comme ils vivent. Ça coûte cher de payer
leur leur majord d'homme, leur
domestique.
Ouais, il faut voir le procès de Marine
Le Pen que je considère être une
procédure politique, hein. Moi, je pense
qu'elle aurait dû être radiée de la
carte politique à cause de ce prêt de 9
millions d'euros, pas à cause de de
l'histoire des assistants
parlementaires, mais il faut voir qu'il
payait. Euh, il y avait le cuisinier, il
y avait le chauffeur, il y avait ça
vient train hein. Il faut pas oublier
que c'est pour eux euh la politique
c'est euh c'est une c'est un c'est des
ressources. Euh quand quand Bardella va
euh à Monaco euh sans canailler pour le
Grand Prix de Formule 1, vous pensez que
Bardella à 30 ans aurait pu être dans
les tribunes VIP euh euh s'il faisait
autre chose que de la politique et aller
après dans des soirées et compagnie. Ces
gens vivent sur la bête. Pourquoi quand
Gabriel Atal privatise,
je sais plus si c'était le palais Dienna
ou atrocadero avec ses journées pour son
14 juillet pour voir les pour voir pour
voir les feux d'artifice.
C'est c'est des petits marquis qui qui
font de l'accès à la ressource une façon
de construire un destin. Sauf que plus
personne comme ils n'ont plus l'ampleur
pour diriger le pays et qu' n'apportent
rien au pays, évidemment derrière on on
se retrouve donc ces gens-là coûtent de
l'argent structurellement. Moi je pense
que pour faire une campagne
présidentielle euh c'est pareil les 50
millions d'euros qu'on attribue à
Nicolas Sarkozy pour sa campagne dit-on
c'est c'est de procédure ça a financé
les appartements d'orfeu de Géant les
tableaux bah oui c'est c'est à la
procédure c'est ce que c'est ce que ces
procédures ont révélé c'est que ces gens
comment Nicolas vous pensez que Nicolas
Sarkozi s'il avait pas fait de la
politique ça avait pas été président de
la République à travers toutes les
méthodes qu'il a utilisé gagnerait
aurait 4 millions d'euros
de revenu sur ses biens,
c'est pas de revenu absolu on est sur si
je me souviens bien au-dessus c'est
qu'il tire juste déjà de dividende du
fait des placements des Je sais plus si
c'était brut ou net parce que ça avait
été lu par le juge qui va juger en appel
justement au moment de de sa mise en
liberté sa demande de mise en liberté en
prison. Le fait que Trump fasse des
pressions sur les juges français qui
pourraient inquiéter Marine Le Pen.
Oui, moi j'ai plein moi j'ai plein des
juges français qui font preuve d'une
d'une impartialité merveilleuse en
France. Maintenant les pauvres petits
après soumis complètement maintenant ils
disent "Oh, on fait précieux sur nous,
c'est pas gentil, c'est pas il faut pas
à un moment donné si on veut être plein,
il faut se montrer à la hauteur de sa
tâche." La justice en France n'est pas
indépendante. La justice en France s'est
soumise au pouvoir existant et à s'est
comporté vraiment de façon indécente à
l'égard d'un certain nombre de personnes
que ce soit pour les protéger. On
parlait de Bigorne, on pourrait parler
de monsieur habitant et et euh et des
blessures anales et vaginales qui lui
ont valu non lieu. Euh ou euh à
l'inverse contre les opposants qu'ils
ont fracasé. Oui, mais moi je peux vous
le raconter en détail parce que j'ai il
y a l'ordonnance de non lieu. Je veux
dire quelqu'un qui a quitté c'est pas
qui c'est pas qui a quitté, c'est pas
qu'il a un non lieu, c'est qu'il est
démis en examen. C'est-à-dire qu'on
considère qu'il a même pas d'indice
grave et concordant alors qu'il laisse
une femme en état de choc traumatique
attesté par le juge par le par le
l'expert le jour même des faits avec
cinq lésions anales, lésions vaginales,
cinq lésions vaginales pardon, lésion
anales, des hématomes,
une serviette imbibé de sang retrouvé
lors de la perquisition le soir même et
ça c'est pas un indice grave ou
concordant d'un viol. Tout ça parce
qu'on est copain avec Brigitte Macron et
qu'on est défendu par les personnes qui
sont les avocats Xavinel et tout ça.
C'est ça la République française
aujourd'hui.
Décision de justice qu'on pas com
Oui. Et donc et donc parce que c'est une
décision de justice parce qu'il y a sep
magistrats, sep juges qui ont considéré
que tout ça ne consistait pas n'était
pas des indices graves ou concordants.
Sep juges, qu'est-ce que ça dit de la
justice française ? Cet argument
d'autorité qui était oui, il y a sep
juges qui ont dit que tout ça qu'il
était innocent. Sep juges ont considéré
que c'était pas des indices graves aux
concordants qu'il y avait un viol. Mais
alors alors quoi ? Question question
internet que je découvre avec vous. La
France est le seul pays au monde à être
présent sur les cinq océans :
Atlantique, Pacifique, Indien, Arctique,
Austral, grâce à son domaine maritime
incluant les territoires ultramarins.
Cette présence est un atout stratégique
majeur en terme de projection, de
puissance, de ressources, de
biodiversité, d'influence géopolitique.
Actuellement, la gestion entre
parenthèses abandon ces territoires en
fait une faiblesse dans le contexte de
guerre hybride actuel et de décadence de
l'armée française. Si monsieur Branco
était au pouvoir, quelles seraient les
solutions et les décisions politiques
militaires et économiques à adopter pour
transformer ses vulnérabilités
en atout ?
C'est une grande des virgues plus que ça
les gars.
Non non mais c'est c'est une question
fondamentale parce que ça c'est c'est
qu'est-ce que la qu'est-ce que doit être
la France ? Est-ce que la France c'est
une Spart qui euh euh comme elle l'a
fait ces 20 30 40 dernières années
intervient régulièrement dans des
domaines militaires y compris pour
entretenir son appareil offensif et qui
utilise ces territoires comme justement
des moyens de projection. Mais des
moyens de projection à quelle fin en
réalité aujourd'hui ? C'est qu'on avait
toute une articulation artificielle sur
Oui, mais le conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU carnaval.
Non mais il faut pas il faut pas être
méprisant à l'égard des populations
ultramarines. Moi en plus moi je
Mais je parle de de la projection
c'estàd
Ah oui oui c'est ça pour pouvoir voilà
le 14 juillet dire bah voyez on est la
grande puissance de tout ce discours qui
qui vient qui vient d'être d'être
discuté et en même temps toutes les
toutes les vecteurs de projection réelle
de puissance. Je vous donne un exemple
Jibouti. Dibouti c'est un espace
fondamental. Moi, j'ai passé un mois
justement pour pour essayer d'analyser
plongé un peu là-bas.
Euh bah, j'ai surtout traversé à mer
rouge pour aller au Yémen. J'ai failli
plonger mais ça aurait pas été très
agréable. Pierre [rires] requin là-bas.
Non, mais surtout il y a des corailles
vivants extraordinaires, des corau
pardon. Et euh et il au se frères où où
j'ai dû passer 24 heures pour éviter les
patrouilles saoudiennes. Mais mais on
est on est sur une avec la DG qui m'a
exiltré d'ailleurs, c'était assez assez
drôle. Euh pourquoi je parle de de
Jibouti ? Djibouti, c'est un une base de
projection très importante au
Moyen-Orient, qui justement dans un
espace cardinal parce que c'est ce qui
permet d'accéder au canal de Suèze et
qui donc est le lieu de transport
maritime par excellence. On était
dominant, d'accord, parce que cit une
ancienne colonie, parce qu'on avait
maintenu des accords de défense.
Aujourd'hui, il y a cinq bases
militaires.
Les Chinois, les même les Japonais, ils
sont aujourd'hui les Italiens, les
Russes et les États-Unis évidemment. et
on se retrouve dans une situation où euh
on ne pèse plus du tout en fait euh dans
la région et on a plus de capacité à
influencer si ce n'est grâce encore une
à notre marine nationale qui nous permet
de de projeter des des bâtiments pour
escorter certains euh certains navires
commerciaux mais qui de toute façon se
sont détournés euh de cette route et et
n'y reviennent pas. C'est intéressant
c'est qu' continue à passer par par
l'Afrique du Sud et le cap de bonne
espérance. Et donc on est dans une
situation où c'est on ne sait plus
pourquoi en fait on a on a ces
territoires et on a bien vu que le
Royaume-Uni avec son Commonwealth en
fait a beaucoup mieux géré la
décolonisation que nous. il avait pas
besoin de maintenir des colonies euh
dans euh sur les cinq euh euh m sur les
cinq océans pour garder une forme de de
de présence et de de puissance
géopolitique.
Euh l'autre enjeu, c'est que ces
populations veulent pas leur
indépendance aujourd'hui. Euh la
Guadeloupe, la Martinique, j'y vais très
souvent, c'est des territoires qui qui
se sentent français et qui ont envie de
le demeurer. Donc il y a aucune raison
de s'en défaire. Par contre, il faut
réfléchir à une gestion complètement
différente de ce territoire. Il faut
arrêter d'envoyer des sous-préfets ou
des préfets comme si c'était des
gouverneurs coloniaux. Il faut
développer en fait, il faut il faut leur
donner une capacité de de gouvernance
locale ou au moins que les fonctions
régaliennes soient occupées par des gens
qui viennent du territoire. Ça ça c'est
la décision de départ la plus importante
pour euh les ultrammarins. Il faut
qu'ils soient jugés par des gens qui
habitent ces territoires, pas des gens
qu'on dépêche là-bas tous les 3 ans. Il
faut qu'il soi euh dirigés par des
préfets qui viennent de ces territoires.
Ça, il faut qu'on sorte avec ce
centralisme qui est complètement
antidémocratique.
Vous connaissez l'ordre mélien ?
Le pardon
l'ordre mélien le dialogue mélien non
je vous conseille c'est très
intéressant. Question internet. Avec la
durée des mandats, comment pensent-il
pouvoir mettre en place tous ces
changements entre parenthèses quand il
faisait référence à de Gou fermer la
parenthèse ?
Ben, on change la durée des mandats et
on
il faut il faut il faut une cohérence
politique sur 15 à 20 ans. Donc il faut
la possibilité euh d'avoir des mandats
renouvelables de 7 ans avec
par contre mandat révocatoire.
C'est-à-dire qu'à tout moment le peuple
peut décider de retirer son mandat à
quelqu'un qui lui a donné. et par
ailleurs les référendum initiatives
citoyennes et les mondes impératifs,
c'est-à-dire la possibilité d'intervenir
directement dans les affaires publiques.
Sinon, on crée un étouffire
démocratique.
Mais il faut il faut de la continuité
évidemment dans une on peut pas on peut
pas on peut pas prétendre que sur un
mandat de 5 ans les choses puissent être
changées de façon les fondamentaux de
notre pays puissent être changés.
Question internet. Bonsoir monsieur que
je découvre avec vous.
Bonsoir monsieur Branco. Abeille de la
ruche 46, j'ai lu le projet version 8
qui me paraît très complet et
parfaitement radical pour créer une
rupture avec le système actuel.
Malheureusement,
étant donné le nombre de propositions
radicales visant directement les élites
et milliardaires, n'avez-vous pas peur
de vous faire disqualifier rapidement
tellement le système est verrouillé ?
Ah oui, bah c'est sûr que on n'est pas à
CNNAFO. On n'a pas le droit des 20h en
ayant fait 0,75 % aux élections.
Elle est pas là pour se défendre.
Toujours les champs les gens qui se
défendre. C'est pas sa faute. C'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas pour contre elle que
je dis ça. C'est juste que on voit bien
la façon dont est organisé l'espace
public et le débat public en France.
Donc il va falloir c'est pour ça que
c'est une responsabilité collective.
C'est notre responsabilité à nous, à
chacun d'entre nous. Par exemple, je
vais vous donner des idées. Il y a des
gens qui ont commencé à faire des shorts
de mes vidéos et des entretiens comme
celle-ci et à les disséminer sur TikTok,
sur Oubliez pas de mettre les sources à
chaque fois et nous soutenir sur [rires]
parce que c'est bien beau de nous diluer
dans la masse internet mais nous on se
prend la tête.
Mais vous voyez mais ça c'est
et notre communauté nous finance pas
pour rien et donc il faut que ce soit un
mouvement vertueux. Donc mais cet
instrument-là en fait c'est facile à
mettre en place et ça permet de
compenser les les centaines de milliers
aux millions d'euros qu'investissent
dans les agences de com nos concurrents.
C'estd qu'il faut en fait à chaque fois
trouver par la base des moyens de
dissémination de nos idées et c'est
devenu possible. Ça vous discuter avec
Sarah Knafou
mais je pense d'ailleurs qu'il y a un
débat de prévu avec elle bientôt. Mais
ouais si on peut si vous voulez le faire
ici je serai ravi. Ouais.
Qu'est-ce que vous faites le 15 ? Euh le
15, je suis ici, je reviens de de Ouais,
ouais, je suis ici. Normement,
je vous appelle demain. Euh la 5e
République est en obsolète. Question
aussi d'internet. La 5e République est
en obsolète. Quelle forme d'organisation
?
Mais vous voulez l'organiser sur le 20h
de TF1 parce sinon c'est pas juste.
Euh bah parce que elle elle a eu droit à
son à ses 5 millions de spectateurs. On
sait pas trop pourquoi. Donc pourquoi
est-ce que est-ce que notre projet
serait moins intéressant ? Parce que
pour l'instant, on n pas de projet.
Nous, on a nous on a fait l'effort, on a
nos 600 euh on a nos 600 propositions.
Allez, on va prendre une dernière
question internet. Euh euh
mais on l'a raté celle-ci, pardon.
Vous disiez, je vous ai interrompu.
Concernant la 5e République étant
obsolète, quelle formule d'organisation
propose ce qu'on vient de proposer, mais
je vous invite vraiment à à lire le
projet parce qu'il y a il y a une
cinquantaine de propositions sur les
institutions à part entière, ce qui nous
pour montrer en fait que ce soit sur la
justice, sur la la fusion du Conseil
d'État de la Cour de cassation et
conseil constitutionnel en une instance
unique avec la création d'un défenseur
du peuple, toute une série de mécanismes
en fait très détaillés. On pourrait
faire toute une toute une un entretien
sur ces seules modifications pour rendre
le pouvoir au peuple.
Question internet,
notre invité parle de services publics
et de prédation des entités privées.
Quit des banques privées auxquelles tout
citoyen est légalement tenu de souscrire
et de leur laisser la propriété de notre
argent entre parenthèses, voir les
conditions générales d'utilisation de
votre banque. Fermez la parenthèse.
Comment on retrouve un pouvoir régalien
sur notre monnaie ? Bah déjà en en
réactivant la Banque de France et en
sortant de Francfort en menant les
mesures qui ont été abandonné sur la
séparation enfin l'équivalent du Glass
Eagle Act de banque de dépôts et enfin
de banques commerciales et de
la séparation des banques commerciales
et des banques d'affaires.
Ouais. Voilà. De de
des institutions financières en créant
un pôle un pôle public du crédit qui
soit unifié. C'est on sort de des
bêtises de la BPI qui ont justement
financé la Start-up Nation et de l'ego
de son directeur qui pense qu'il est
honorable pour au fonctionnaire. Je je
parle de monsieur Dufour que vous
devriez inviter d'ailleurs euh
d'intervenir dans le débat public alors
que il n'a aucun mandat pour le faire et
alors qu' en fait il est censé agir pour
l'État de façon neutre avec un devoir de
réserve et euh et qui donne des leçons
du haut de ses salaires mi brûlant.
Voilà, je pense qu'il y a il y a toute
une série d'actions là là pareil sur sur
la question financière avec justement le
contrôle de change qui à travers la
sortie de l'euro nous permettent de
reprendre un peu la main sur les flux
financiers et une définciarisation de
l'économie qui est devenue urgente et
nécessaire parce qu'autrement ça va on
sera les premiers à subir les
conséquences de la prochaine crise qui
va nécessairement intervenir. on
pourrait parler hein de ce qui est en
train de se passer là avec euh les le
caractère absolument délirant des
valorisations
boursières dans le monde occidental et
des conséquences que ça va avoir quand
quand ça va exploser. L'IBEX euh donc
par exemple le l'équivalent du CAC 40 en
Espagne euh a pris l'équivalent des 20
dernières années en 6 mois de
valorisation. C'est c'est une folie. on
est en train de de se précipiter dans
une création artificielle de valeur dont
on voit bien qu'elle est inexistante
parce que les gens souffrent pour se
loger, pour se chauffer, pour consommer
trois fois rien. Et on est on est en
train de provoquer une crise où si on
reprend pas les le contrôle sur les
instruments avant que ce soit trop tard,
et bien on va le payer très cher.
Question internet,
tu peux changer. Ouais. Comment monsieur
Brancou considère l'immigration pour la
France ? Opportunité ou charge ? Faut-il
réduire ou l'encourager ? Un sujet aussi
clivant pour la pop
quelqu'un qui est tombé. Non,
optimiste.
Un sujet aussi clivant pour la
population mérite d'être abordé et ne
l'est malheureusement pas dans le
programme actuel. entre parenthèses de
ce que j'ai pu en
Oui, il est plus sérieusement que tous
les autres parce que dès dès qu'on sort
de l'Union européenne, on reprend le
contrôle sur les frontières et donc sur
la politique migratoire. Ça c'est quand
même le point de départ. Ensuite et donc
on rend la possibilité au peuple
français de décider quelle politique il
adopte sur ces questions. Ensuite, il y
a la question qui est beaucoup traitée
par Madame Mfo, à mon avis pas dans le
bon sens sur la politique de
coopération. Nous, on revient par
exemple à une politique de coopération
purement bilatérale. On sort de tous ces
grands fonds dans lesquels on investit
des milliards le plus souvent à la
citation américaine pour avoir une
coopération avec les pays tiers
seulement basé sur les fondamentaux, les
la recherche, l'éducation, la langue
française. Je veux dire, je rappelle
qu'Emmanuel Macron a confié
l'Organisation internationale de la
francophonie à une représentante d'un
état qui avait renoncé au français comme
langue officielle. Le ronda c'est dire à
quel point on était en terme de de
trahison. Et donc on reprend en fait on
redonne les instruments de contrôle de
décision aux français. les frontières le
cont le le narco, pardon mais c'est
l'espace Schengen c'est que c'est à un
moment donné il y a une
déresponsabilisation collective sur le
contrôle des frontières donc les fus à
la fois humain et de marchandises et
donc évidemment qu'on perd et c'est ça
qui crée la crise aussi identitaire que
connaî moi je pense que la crise
identitaire française il y a deux choses
la perte de contrôle sur les frontières
immédiate mais aussi mais aussi la perte
euh de contrôle sur notre appareil
productif ce que je dis à chaque fois
c'estàd que quand on on on consomme et
on euh des produits qui n'ont plus aucun
lien avec notre territoire, qui ne
disent plus rien de ce qu'on est. Quand
on s'habille comme s'habillerait
n'importe quel membre d'une classe
moyenne mondialisée, on finit par ne
plus se reconnaître. Oui, on finit par
ne plus avoir d'identité en propre et
donc on cherche à se distinguer. On on
commence à ça génère une angoisse, une
angoisse de soi, une angoisse de la vie
dans laquelle on parce que il y a plus
de dispositif en fait de dispositif de
reconnaissance de de savoir qui fait
partie de notre espace plus ou moins
proche, qui est notre allié, qui est
notre ennemi. Et donc on se retrouve
dans cette situation où à un moment
donné, on finit par par vouloir projeter
cette angoisse sous forme de violence à
l'égard de tiers. Donc il y a toute une
série comme ça d'éléments qui
m'apparaissent euh font mandamont et
après, il va y avoir un travail très
important à mettre en œuvre à l'égard
euh euh des puissances de la
Méditerranée. Je pense que la la France
comme puissance méditerranéenne, ça va
être un vrai sujet et sur notre capacité
à réguler. Euh moi je me suis beaucoup
engagé par exemple sur la révolution au
Sénégal.
C'était aussi dans l'espoir que le
peuple sénégalais retrouve un désir de
demeurer notamment de sa jeunesse et de
pas prendre le risque de couler en dans
l'Atlantique ou dans le désert. Voilà.
et pour et et c'est pas forcément la
source migratoire la plus
déstabilisatrice parce que il y a quand
même des proximités culturelles qui ont
été forgé à travers le temps
mais il faut il faut quand même voir
voyez ce que ça produit comme à la fois
comme fumoin comme désespoir et comme
comme effet d'opportunité pour toute une
série de réseaux mafieux qui les
récupèrent et qui en font de la chair à
canon.
Question internet. Monsieur Branco,
pense pensez-vous être encore vivant en
2027 ?
C'est c'est une bonne question parce
qu'il y a plusieurs formes de mort. Il y
a la mort physique, le et il y a la mort
sociale. C'est la capacité à un moment
donné à à survivre à toutes les
offensives réputationnelles. J'avais
hésité en venant vous voir parce que
beaucoup de gens ne savent pas euh euh
qui je suis euh et euh et j'avais hésité
à refaire une présentation qui fasse un
peu contrepoids. C'est intéressant en
fait. C'est là où on mesure le le la
vérité de l'engagement et la violence
qu'on subi en retour. Vous lisez ma page
Wikipédia, on dirait la page Wikipédia
de Gillor ou de Barbe Bleu. Enfin, je
dirais il y a pas plus monstrueux comme
être humain tel que qu'on vous présente
à travers la lecture de d'accumulation
en fait d'offensive réputationnelle qui
à chaque fois trouvent leur inscription,
voilà, qui est durable euh et qui font
que on finit par dire mais c'est pas
possible, un bon pareil ne peut pas
exister. Vous voyez, enfin ça devient
ridicule. Et donc à un moment donné ces
effets de marginalisation évidemment ça
devient une force parce que il y a une
telle concentration de ressources pour
essayer de nous délégitimer qu'on finit
par se dire c'est pas possible c'est qui
se met qu'est-ce qu'il a pu faire pour
énerver autant de gens. Mais il faut pas
qu'on oublie que si il y a un certain
nombre de personnes qui sont conscients
de comment se fabrique aujourd'hui euh
les réputations, comment les oligarques
interviennent, les réseaux et
compagnies, il y a beaucoup de gens qui
sont encore prisonniers qui ont encore
pour source euh d'information
principale, euh bah les chaînes en
continu les 20hurs et ne se rendent pas
compte à la fois de l'état de prédation
que connaît notre pays. Là, on a on
parle un peu en initié. En réalité,
c'est peut-être un défaut qu'on a, c'est
que on aborde avec naturalité des sujets
qui sont relativement techniques quand
même et on donne l'impression que il y
aura une forme
une forme de consens
consensualité pardon au sujet de ce dont
on parle. En réalité, en réalité, on est
très minoritaire encore au sein de la
population. On a que 1,3 million
d'abonnés et certes, on est connu
partout dans la francophonie en France.
Ouais. Mais c'est l'élite.
C'est vrai que la majeure partie des
gens métro boulot dodo, problème
d'argent, problème.
Ils ont pas 3 heur à et et c'est et
c'est le problème de ce format
paradoxalement, c'est qu'en fait
c'est pas un problème parce que les gens
comme les gens font du sport, les gens
aiment bien s'endormir. La salle, la
salle c'est un très un grand symptôme de
de déréli
en faisant en faisant du ménage parce
que nous
Oui, le ménage oui mais non le ménage on
est obligé de le faire mais le sport
individualisé cette solitude
existentielle dans laquelle on est
plongé voyez c'est plus le sport comme
collectif ou comme dynamique de
développement du technique d'interaction
avec un autre et cetera le sport comme
jogging comme ça les compagnies c'est un
symptôme d'une société qui se referme
sur elle-même d'une société où le lien
c'est un compensatoire oui voilà mais
c'est bien ce que je dis c'est pour ça
voilà pour Nous le sport maintenant ça
devient tout de suite la la solitude. Il
y a quelque chose là qui qui pour moi
est très symptomatique et et qui est une
perte de de repère parce que ça rejoint
ce qu'on a pas développé sur ce qui être
une jeune femme ou un jeune homme
aujourd'hui. C'est c'est un monde en
miroir où en fait à chaque fois c'est se
faire du sport pour le miroir ressembler
à quelque chose dans l'espoir que ça va
générer un lien. là où au départ le
sport était un vecteur de lien en soi.
Vous voyez, quel que soit votre le
nombre d'abdos que vous aviez ou euh et
et on est on est face à un vrai
fondement civationnel qui ira bien
au-delà de toute cette tout ce dont on a
parlé là manque quelque part un peu de
spiritualité. C'estd qu'on a on n pas on
a peut-être pas parlé du fondamental qui
est de la mise en valeur de façon
beaucoup plus profonde de ce que en fait
c'est même plus d'être français, c'est
d'être un être humain. Enfin, vous voyez
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire et qu'est-ce
qu'on défend à travers le politique et
fait du rugby ?
Bah par exemple, oui, en
fondamentalement. Ouais.
Sinon, ça s ça ça s'écoute bien au lancé
de Javel.
Ouais. [rires]
Mais qui au moins est un sport qui
développe une technicité. Vous voyez ce
que je veux dire ? C'est pas pour rien
que c'était aux olymp aux olympiades et
qui servait à quelque chose à l'époque
on lançait des javelot pour faire la ga
mais je me la raconte he mais j'ai fait
un entraînement de rugby et je me suis
fait les croiser donc trois
entraînements de rugby au troisème je me
suis fait recroiser
encore un physique de chétif [rires]
euh et oui nous nous on était talonneur
et
il vous voilà les gens ne vous voient
pas mais c'est vrai que c'est un autre
physique. Ouais.
Et donc revenons. Vous croyez en Dieu ?
Je je crois que c'est très très
important. J'ai découvert assez tard les
évangiles
selon qui ? Bah, je préfère celui selon
Saint-Mthieu en les lisant tous et je
les ai découvert à travers parce que je
sais qu'on arrive, j'ai l'impression
qu'on arrive sur la fin et vous faites
souvent des des conseils de lecture. Je
vais vous faire un conseil de
d'ailleurs on devance pas mes questions.
Non, mais de visionnage. C'est pour ça
c'est pas c'est c'est [rires] évangile
selon sur la nature un malin.
Mais mais mais en fait non mais c'est
parce que c'est pour
on invite Ran Branco pour faire la
rentrée parce que on a beaucoup de
respect pour lui parce que c'est un
homme de parole et c'est pas une
balance.
[rires]
Et on a on a on a pu le tester et c'est
pas une balance
et je pense que c'est important que les
gens de lecture avant que je m'énerve.
C'est pas un conseil de lecture, c'est
un conseil de visionnage. Mais pourquoi
je dis ça ? parce qu'en fait, il y a eu
à la fois une histoire d'amour qui m'a
qui m'a fait découvrir cette pensée
chrétienne qui m'échappait un peu malgré
le fait que mes parents étaient levés
par les jésuites. Vous savez, ils font
partie de cette génération bien
mais ils ont fait font partie de cette
génération qui qui s'était complètement
défaite de ces structures parce qu'il
les considérait acquises. Et en fait
évidemment quand quand c'est un une
donnée, vous rendez pas forcément compte
de la valeur qu'elles ont et vous pensez
que vous pouvez vous construire sans
avoir à je sais pas si à les transmettre
mais en tout cas sans avoir à les
perpétuer. Et je pense que c'est le
grand drame de notre modernité
d'ailleurs. Et donc ces évangiles et
l'histoire de Jésus telle qu'elle nous a
été contée et qu'elle et qu'elle en fait
sert de points de repère sur un certain
nombre de justement de principes qui
sont suprapolitiques et c'est très
important pour toutes les générations en
particulier les nouvelles, ce qui ne
veut pas dire faire du prosélitisme
religieux mais de se confronter à ces
textes qui ont fondé 2000 ans
d'histoires en fait de notre histoire.
On peut pas se comprendre si on ne sait
pas de quoi on part, quand bien même on
soit devenu une société laïque où on est
passé de 80 à 30 % de croyants en même
pas 30 ans, ce qui est d'ailleurs une
rupture phénoménale qui est pas du tout
étudiée par les appareils politiques.
Comment ça se fait qu' a eu cet
effondrement de la croyance ? C'est très
intéressant. C'est pas un jugement
d'ailleurs, c'est juste Et qu'est-ce que
ça change ? Bah ça change tout en fait
en réalité parce que à travers la
croyance c'est toute une série de
valeurs, de principes de modes de
comportement qui était qui était
transmis. C'est c'est comme
mais c'est comme le livre comme vecteur
de transmission d'information, vous
voyez. C'est juste on lit plus de
livres, on lit d'autres choses. Mais
avec le changement de modalité de
transmission le type de savoir aussi
change.
Trois livres à conserver [rires] à la
communauté.
Bah donc l'Évangile selon Saint-Mthieu,
ça c'est de la triche.
Euh
le livre de Bruno Lebert.
Non non. Quoi que je les avais lu hein
et et on est on est tous un peu bêtes
dans cette époque he pour être tout à
fait honnête et et moi j'ai lu les
livres de Bruno Lemè et en fait le
garçon
les avaz acheté
je les avais acheté à l'époque ou ouais
et avant avant qu'il soit ministre de
l'économie parce qu'en fait il a
commencé à écrire quand il était
conseiller de Dominique de Villepin qui
était ministre les affaires étrangères
il y a il y a 20 ans de ça donc vraiment
son premier livre son premier livre a
été très loué comme étant une façon de
comprendre de l'intérieur le
fonctionnement des arcanes du politique.
Sauf que il y avait déjà
il y avait déjà ces morceaux d'intimité
un peu je sais pas si dégoûtant mais
enfin en tout cas décalé. Il y a pas il
y a pas de truc dégoûtant dans
Non mais dégoûtant au sens où on n pas
envie de le lire, voyez. Enfin enfin, on
n pas envie de savoir ces choses-là.
Mais mais
vousimaginez pas Bruno,
on a on a en tout cas pas lui en tout
cas par ailleurs. Enfin voyez mais mais
qu'importe pourquoi je vous raconte ça ?
C'est parce que ces livres en fait ont
croyez en Dieu.
Donc je
Tu as fait le malin ? Tu vas pas faire
le malin 5 minutes, hein. Donc vous
croyez en Dieu
euh
nominé tr spirit.
Non mais parce que je vais souvent à la
messe
en latin ou pas en latin ?
Non, pas en latin. Euh
tu es pas un puriste mon ami.
Je Bah c'est la messe de mon quartier
hein. Pardon c'est pas moi qui choisit
mes mes curées. Mais mais je je pour
être tout à fait honnête euh
oui ou non. Je fais pas la communion
parce que je crois pas surtout dans la
en fait vous savez l'église a ce truc
un peu non c'est un peu chelou c'est qu'
il vous le
corps du Christ
il Non mais il vous force à à quelque
part à jurer sur le fait que vous croyez
en l'autorité de l'église et et
notamment en la résurrection. Euh il y a
toute une série de précepts qu'il faut
accepter à travers la communion qui me
semblent pas nécessaires
et qui m'intéresse moins que les
principes évangéliques
et
sort les rames oui ou non.
Je vais vous dire encore autre chose.
Euh,
vas-y, prépare.
Une brique. On lui jeter une brique.
Quand ma quand ma grand-mère est morte
quand j'avais 17 ans.
Non, on a pas dit on Non, ça
si c'est important. Elle est restée avec
moi pendant très longtemps, au point où
à un moment donné euh dans ce sorte de
dialogue intérieur que j'avais avec
elle, parce une présence affective qui a
été très importante dans ma vie, je lui
ai dit "C'est bon, je lui demandais de
l'aide à chaque fois." Je disais et au
début quand j'avais 17 ans c'était
j'aimerais bien avoir VO en anglais ou
je sais pas quoi na ça marchait assez
bien avec quelques semaines de décalage
et au bout 10 ans, j'ai dit tu peux
partir. Enfin je me suis dit je la
retiens là. Enfin elle veut enfin
dissipe-toi dans les terres ou ou
qu'importe. Etth et j'ai regretté de
l'avoir fait. Donc je crois j'ai je
crois en des formes de présence. C'est
c'est très important en fait. Ouais
c'est ce que quelle forme elles ont.
Voilà.
On était à combien de bouquins là ?
Euh bah zéro. vu que vous avez pas
accepté l'Évangile selon selon Saint
Matthieu
trois bouquins rapidous
est-ce que je peux pas recommander trois
films
si bien sûr
alors bah la passion selon sainture de
Pasolini [rires]
mé de Pasolini allez un film très beau
mé de Pasolini de gladiateur
et pourquoi pasolini c'est important
c'est parce que c un grand intellectuel
et qui était à la fois dans le politique
à la fois poète à la fois cinéaste et
qu'à un moment donné cette cette une
radicalité incroyable communiste et
chrétien euh
c'est c'est quelqu'un qui a réussi avoir
une forme de transgression très
fructifaire pour la société.
H je pense que c'est très important de
revoir Apocalypse Now maintenant que les
spectres de la guerre reviennent parce
que c'est le plus grand film je pense
qui a été fait avec peut-être la ligne
rouge de Terrain Malik sur la guerre.
C'est très très important.
Et euh
et al et d'autres d'autres et peut-être
un livre mais que je recommande à chaque
fois mais que j'ai j'ai recommandé aussi
parce que il traite de la Première
Guerre mondiale, voyage au bout de la
nuit de de Céline, c'est classique mais
c'est important parce qu'il
malgré ses positions tendancieuses sur
deux trois trucs.
Mais parce que c'est sans importance par
rapport à son génie littéraire et parce
que il a il a raconté la guerre comme
peu de personnes l'ont fait. et que il y
a deux façons de de savoir ce qui est
vraiment la guerre à part la vivre.
C'est de regarder les vidéos de drone
qu'il y a aujourd'hui sur le front
russo-ukrainien pour comprendre que
l'horreur que consiste de se confronter
face à la mort parce que aujourd'hui on
a le droit à des centaines de milliers
de vidéos où on voit le dernier visage
avant la mort de quelqu'un qui fait face
à une mort barbare parce que c'est une
mort téléguidée et et ça dit quelque
chose de notre humanité. Et sinon la
lecture de d'œuvre comme celle-ci qui
raconte en fait sur la durée ce que
c'est que de se confronter à à à la mort
sans encore une fois sans jugement de
valeur sur la nécessité au nom de la
guerre. Mais quand on parle de la guerre
sacrifice ou pas ?
Ouais, ça j'y crois. Mais vous savez,
moi j'ai j'ai perdu beaucoup de joie en
m'engageant dans l'espace public ces 10
dernières années. Ça a été d'une
violence
qui est très très difficile à à énoncer
et qui et que je n'anticipais pas. et
euh et c'est c'est
un modus vivendy qui m'apparaît qui
m'apparaît fondamental de monnaie à
bout. En fait, il y a pas de et quand
quand je prends le risque
euh de sortir du Sénégal dans une
pirogue
dans une Ouais. Enfin comme le font tant
de gens qui fuient leur malheur, mais là
dans cette dans cette hypothèse pour
essayer de sortir mon client de la de la
situation dans laquelle il s'était
retrouvé euh et que je sais très bien
qu'il y a des chances importantes que je
me rennoyais et que ça faillit être le
cas d'ailleurs et ça prend 25 heures et
qu'ensuite je prends le risque de de
passer perpétuité en prison puisque
c'était de ça dont j'étais menacé.
Euh je le fais en en en avec cet esprit
que on fait partie d'un grand tout en
fait d'un plus grand temps vous parliez
de la question de croire en Dieu. Je
pense qu'il faut croire aussi en
l'humanité comme comme une sorte de
corps à nourrir en fait. Et il faut se
il faut se donner à ce corps son naïveté
son son gratuité excessive. Il faut le
faire avec cette force et cette volonté
de défendre ses idées. Mais à chaque
fois qu'on a l'opportunité, il faut il
faut y aller. Ouais.
Le crédau
et c'est parce qu'en fait c'est aussi ça
qui permet, vous voyez quand vous me
dites "Est-ce que vous allez réussir à
dominer ces gens ? Est-ce que vous allez
réussir à faire autorité ?" Moi je crois
que les parcours disent quelque chose et
finissent aussi par créer une forme de
d'autorité naturelle que d'autres dont
d'autres manquent aujourd'hui au sein de
notre société.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations,
bouteille à la mer, quelque chose qui
restera impérissable. Moi je pense
s'acheter un globe terrestre parce que
comprendre
Oui, c'est pas impérissable mais c'est
important pour l'époque. Euh on a un
copain qui a fait une application
pas longtemps non non en acheter un
physiquement et revoir ce qu'est le
monde euh non pas sous la forme
planisphère mais avec les vraies
proportions. C'est-à-dire en et là vous
allez voilà vous allez voir le monde tel
qui tel dans ses grandes évidemment
proportions. Mais mais c'est très
important de se figurer. Vous comprenez
ce qui se passe au Vénézuela et et
pourquoi Cuba est un point de tension
aussi important pour les États-Unis en
voyant sur ces projections là euh la la
déjà la taille et aussi la proximité
qu'il y a par exemple les États-Unis.
Des exemples comme celui-ci, je peux
vous les multiplier sur l'ensemble des
conflits auxquels on est confronté.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
On voulait embrasser nos agriculteurs
et Ron Branco. Bonne année et merci.
Merci à vous et merci aux agriculteurs.
[musique]